I like how you're just keep posing.
You're like standing with an emoji in front of the computer.
You?
Come here.
Again.
Come over here.
I'm getting in the pillow pile.
Yeah, we're in a little pillow fort.
We're in a pillow fort.
Hi, everybody.
Tell me if I need to turn it up again.
Yeah.
But don't be too picky.
We can only do so much.
Exactly.
My mic is on a pillow.
Lucky you're getting fed this stream tonight.
Yeah.
You're lucky.
Oh, it's quiet.
Okay, hold on.
I can turn it up.
Maybe that was better.
Is it better?
Can you guys hear us?
Oh, I think so.
I don't already see it.
Wait.
Wait, that's pretty good.
When did you learn this lab?
What do you mean, it's my Pomeranian.
Matara brought her famous Pomeranian here.
Normal guy.
We're going to get kicked out.
We're going to get a complaint.
But who brought this dog?
Who led the dogs?
Speaking of dogs being out.
You guys have your, I always wear socks.
Our dogs are out.
I usually do, but it's summer.
Get the dogs out for summer.
Mimi and I just met were drinking.
We are.
Yeah, we're drinking, buddy.
And our dog, you're out.
I'm drinking mango juice and orange juice is my original
cocktail.
This girl, I bring the juice and she's like, I say, would
you like a mix of orange and mango juice?
She goes, yeah, why'd you buy mango juice, by the way?
I was scared that you hated mangoes.
I have a trauma with me.
Wait, do you?
No.
No, she was like, yeah, I'd love that.
Yeah, I was so excited.
Why'd you get that?
Who is she?
We also have watermelon, macaroons, pineapple, and then Nimi
and I are drinking little mimosas.
Yeah, with mimosas.
Yeah, no mimosas.
No mimosas.
Wait, is that what it is, a mimosa?
Yeah, it's orange juice and Prosecco, sparkling wine.
Oh.
But I did go a little heavy-handed on the orange juice.
Like, I went very heavy on the juice at first.
Oh.
So now we're gonna have to like...
If Nimi is quiet, it's because she's quiet.
It's because I am quiet.
Yeah.
I exhaust, I made her carry all the groceries.
I like, please bump NIMI volume.
We're on one mic, you guys.
NIMI, you gotta scream.
Maybe get closer.
I can get closer.
Yeah, don't worry, she hasn't drunk enough yet.
When I stream, I do talk like this close.
Really?
I guess I do too.
I just turn it down.
Do shrimp when you do it then?
Like you're kind of over the mic.
I do, I do.
Well, my microphones come up, so maybe I just like raise it.
It's like, you know those seals when they're like, Yes.
Cute.
Yay.
Nimmy shrimp.
Yeah.
She eats the microphone.
Yummy.
Well, right now we could pet it because it's got fuzzy on
it.
Does this sound like ASMR?
Oh yeah, you know the ASMR.
But I don't know how it sounds.
Does it sound good, you guys?
Hold on.
The ASMRs, they go.
They go .
Does that?
Did you know that?
Oh.
I don't know.
She's looking at you like, oh, no, that was great.
That was so really nice.
Can you rate my Yuyasa Moro's out?
10.
10 out of 10.
Wow.
I'm so odd.
Guys, my Oshi said I'm 10 out of 10.
That's right.
Why are you guys lying to mint?
This is not good.
No.
I want a watermelon.
I try to move it a little bit here because I'm worried it
might spill.
Have you had any fruit?
Never in my life.
Have I had a fruit?
Have you had fruit today?
Dave?
No.
Let me give you the fork.
I don't need a fork.
Okay.
She's going Finkies deep.
Finkies in.
Mommy.
Oh yeah.
You don't have a fork.
No we have extra forks.
I don't need it.
You don't need a fork for fruit.
She's an animal.
Animal.
A true vegan can eat fruit with just their hands.
That's the real you have no no nothing.
The worst part is mint and I have macaroons and every
macaroon we eat we're like yummy so good like this one is so
delicious and then we just stared neemie in the eyes so
delicious yeah do you want me to like blow my breath into
your oh you're back i wasn't getting it i eat it and then
i'm like guys i don't think she's into it Give me your
review.
You could smell all of them.
I don't need to smell them.
There's nothing worse, I think, than smelling something
yummy.
No!
That's like a diet tactic, no?
You smell it and then you eat.
That's sad.
That's like what you do to a toddler.
To get them to eat their vegetables.
Real talk.
I'd rather not smell something if I know I can't eat it.
And it's gonna smell delicious, right?
I agree.
Yes.
So anyway, you should smell this.
Alright, do you want salted caramel next, coconut or lemon?
Caramel.
Let's do it.
Okay, everybody, here's our review for, not you, for Nimmy
Nightmas.
Oh, also both Mint and I, we first grabbed, the first
macaron that we grabbed was pink, so we both thought it was
going to be raspberry, and it was...
It wasn't bad, but when you expect raspberry...
Who makes a fig macaron?
It smells...
Staring, staring, staring.
it's does this smell okay hold on i'm gonna grab this one
and see if it's oh it does smell like coconut okay i don't
know how to tell you also you touched it you have to eat it
i would this one is so good oh please don't look if you need
me this is so delicious can i ruin figs for you do you know
the secret of figs no i don't know it they're not vegan well
they are well they are in wait what no they're in a they're
in a symbiotic relationship with wasps so every fig is
fertilized by dead wasps a wasp has to die it goes in think
to be but it wants to die it wants to die it's part of its
life life cycle it's natural wait actually yeah yeah it but
it gets absorbed by the fig and the fig turns it a wasp died
for your sins today can you believe this I'm gonna plant
Why don't we have more figs?
Wait!
No, the wasps are the ones I think that don't sting you, or
they do sting you.
No, they do.
Wasps are evil.
Yeah, okay, plant fig trees.
Only bit.
New age cafe is just fig trees.
Yeah.
Dang.
They'll be a funny side bit if you just, like, get a little
fig tree.
A little fig.
Yeah, add it to my cafe.
One fig tree.
Then the wasps will come, though.
You gotta, like, sequester it.
But yeah, but until they do that.
die they're gonna be they're gonna be stinging your
customers it's a retirement home you can put the who put the
fig tree in the section with the bad customers oh the
customers who annoy you there if ever a little whisp is
being a little out of out of sorry okay with I tease her so
wasps wasps with I can't I can say wasps with so she can't
pronounce whips I can I just is that why you change the and
I said this you guys can't bully her that's mean but as her
friend like it's rude if I don't someone's got to do it I
it's like activates my stutter I have that like weighted
best when I say it when I randomly say it I sound like
weighted list the double use are really hard for Eastern
Europeans I want to wear my weighted waist this never
happens by the way I never have somebody I set out my drink
a little tonight and Mimi volunteers like I'll drink with
you because no nobody drinks I know sorry this is so
exciting I'm drinking and she has her dogs out and we have
the Pomeranian dog here
but yeah so um what are you girls doing here what are we
doing yeah why are you here we're hanging out yeah down the
street yeah same old thing i don't know we're just we're
just having a girl's night you guys yeah we got face masks
we do actually courtesy mataro's looked like it was like a
gelatin almost it kind of looked like you said like baloney
yeah it was like the scene in the office yeah where Dwight
is imitating the silence of the lambs and he's got the
baloney on his face also if i had like a casanova moment i
ruined it i was pouring nimi alcohol i was i was you know
talking to her all seductively and then my mask just started
like healing and i pulled up i had to grab it and then it
all kept falling and nimi god bless you you just kept
talking she's like i don't notice a thing it was kind of
horrifying it was like already partially ripped so it was
just like phantom of the opera like you know those cheap
hams that are like very That's what it looked like I had on
my face.
Yeah, like an artificial ham pink.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah.
Did you taste it?
What if it was ham?
What if?
I can bring it up if you'd like to smell it.
From the trash.
I put it in the trash, yeah.
What?
There were cherries on the bathroom floor.
I tried to buy cherries today, but they didn't have any.
Or we can find, we did look, but we like also did look
everywhere.
No, I think- We speed ran.
I think a watermelon is good.
I had to warn Nimi that if we weren't going to get out of
here, I was just going to add more stuff.
And she had to carry all of it.
She was like struggling.
I was very strong.
I was not struggling.
I know.
They came.
Yeah.
You guys came into my hotel room and Nimi is holding
everything.
Hey, she's a strong, independent woman.
She's not very strong.
Wait, I dripped on my hand.
Hold on.
You can.
What?
wipe it on my pants.
I'm gonna throw them in the wash when I get home.
I thought you were gonna say you throw them out.
Yeah, for real though.
I don't mind.
Oh my gosh, they are.
They, oh my gosh, she's rubbing it in.
Oh my goodness.
That was a, that was a- No, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
It honestly doesn't feel at all.
And was that not seductive enough for you?
to watch as a viewer I mean it's just getting in there
because it's like it might what do you call this the cracks
of your fingers maybe it probably has a name yeah well
quickly everybody Google it what is it what is it so when
you do a peace sign oh the webbing yeah the webbing some
people are born with webbed fingers I've heard I've heard
that yeah apparently makes you for like slightly better
swimmer I don't know if it's a swimmer or not would you put
your cup down please yes I believe that though because then
you're just like a frog or a duck also we are drinking
Nimi's recommendation and it's very yummy is it I was I was
put on the spot I was like I don't know I usually buy the
cheapest one right now is it carbonated yeah it's sparkling
do you want a little sippy I can't have a carbonation oh I
love you I teaser will we go to Japan She's always teasing
me.
She will order, like, corn sushi and egg sushi, and it's
just, like, what kids order, and I love it.
It's my favorite thing.
So, I can't have it anyway.
An Appy juice.
Oh, actually, I was told to get more Appy juice.
I was, someone was just like, we have Appy juice.
We'd love to give it to you.
Because I already have two bottles in here.
I also like Prosecco without juice, but.
I'm good, thank you.
juice I tried to impress them with my waitressing skills and
then the moment I opened the juice spilled it the moment I
dropped ice spilled juice everything I fumbled fumbled I got
two beautiful women and I'm fumbling oh my god can you
believe this it's a good trope clumsy waitress yeah actually
this weekend in Vegas there was a waiter I think I already
told me me he um he spilled his whole like he was reaching
to give my friend actually a mango smoothie and he dropped
it it was it was glass it spilled fully like broke next to
me it splashed me everything no and then my friend it was
also really funny because we were so stressed not stressed
but we were like sun hung over because we're on the lazy
river with like a little floaties we were so tired and i was
sitting like this with my glasses like i just wasn't looking
and then he spilted i was like it's fine hold on don't worry
about it i'm gonna turn off the bgm so that we're easier to
hear but um so i already have like clumsy waiter experience
this weekend now you get to live get to be the worst clumsy
waitressing I've ever did I used to work at a breakfast
restaurant when I was really young I spilled a whole hot I
had cups of hot coffee and I spilled them at a table that
also had kids at it no so I spilled hot coffee on children
and you know what I do it again sometimes they need that
sometimes they deserve it send them to send them to the figs
what a threat you're being a little wasp right now Yeah.
Ma, send him to the fig.
I'm being a little curmudgeon-y today.
I learned a new word.
Yeah.
What was the word?
Curmudgeon.
Or curmudgeonly.
Where does that come from?
It sounds like a little, I don't know, ridge troll or
something.
A karm is like a little young man who when he used to
misbehave in Victorian times would get whipped.
Oh.
U-R-M.
Oh, wow.
I believe it.
Wait, are you making that up?
No.
Oh, wait, I actually can't tell.
Yeah, it's real.
Is this real?
It's real.
I never lied to you.
Wait, what?
Where?
No, I learned the word today.
It's not true.
Oh!
Thanks for backing me up, Nibi.
Oh my god.
I said it's my duty to bully my friend you know did I
thought that you looked it up for something after you
learned no I'm just really smart you just you absorb that my
brain just does that sometimes Charles Dickens literally
possessed you I have cholera you don't want cholera not the
demure thing I know I hope you get dysentery I always used
to say like history because I didn't know how to pronounce
dysentery.
Did you play Oregon Trail?
No, but I want to.
I want to play it.
Yeah.
Did you just, didn't you play the remake?
Yeah, I did.
There's also like a zombie version.
There's Oregon Trail.
Yeah, Oregon Trail.
Yeah.
Maybe that's the zombie.
I know there was like Death Road to Canada.
That one's good.
I played it.
It's really fun.
It's like you're, you have little guys and you collect them
and then you have to like whip zombies as you're going
through.
I think you'd really like it.
Wait, that sounds fun.
But you kind of have to luck out and get like a rare
character because they're usually much stronger but it's
actually really relatable and you can name people after us
you can and then you'll have like me and her in the car and
we'll die yeah we might have to leave one of us on the road
oh my god who would i choose
she pointed at me instantly
you running after the car
and you actually could because you could be like well matara
you're really your limbs are heavy you got all the buck
claws like oh yeah because you need to use gas efficiently
gas is your most efficient resource oh so you throw me out i
don't know i can't drive
so what do you what do you offer i'm a nurse i'm a nurse
she's a nurse and she's moe that's so true and she's vegan
so you'd have more food oh i might starve though we know we
give you the grass she's willing to pay someone put nurse in
quotes no I'm well do you need your nurse to be licensed how
important is that you have a name tag I think that's yeah
exactly I watched your ASMR when you were like oh when I
removed the break see you got to be pretty skilled okay okay
okay Matara what do you offer just just drop okay i already
know there's no point it's just gonna embarrass me to like
beg for my life honestly i don't even know what i would
offer well you can drive oh i can't drive honestly that in
itself is good enough i have a license for real everybody a
license to kill by the way mint made the stream chat so much
bigger for me no me too i couldn't read it either maybe I
could maybe I don't think you could have read it now it's
readable but before that it was time it was really oh but
you guys need to know we can see like four lines yeah thank
you for the super chats but unfortunately they go like very
fast so I can't read them so here's an idea you guys
everybody get together and write one letter in the super
chat oh so that way it's like a whole we can read it's it's
zoomed in 150 times because it's a we're sitting on the
floor like a little it's fine puppy pal pile and and the
monitor is on the desk so it's kind of far you guys hello hi
I saw you say that they were able to write one word so is I
think that's an upside-down P right that letter Or is that,
oh, it's a B.
It's because in Russian, that's actually a letter.
No, you're right, actually.
It's a soft sign.
In Russian, that's a real letter of the alphabet.
In Cyrillic.
No, that is an upside-down P. I repurposed it.
Like, I paid for this.
I'm going to use it.
Wait, so they could spell booby?
Yes, that's why you made it?
No, I actually don't remember why I put the B.
Can we get a booby, please?
One booby in the chat, please.
I prefer two.
if possible.
One is not enough.
Multiples of two, please.
Boobie, boobie, boobie, boobie, boobie.
I'm so glad I can read the chat.
Boobie, boobie, boobie, boobie.
Oh, I love when they spell onion.
Oh, onion.
Okay, okay, what else can you guys spell?
Show me everything you guys can spell.
Moo.
I feel like this is what having kids is going to be like.
Boobie, boobie, onion, onion.
I'm thoroughly entertained by this.
Show me what other words you guys know.
It's today.
It's today's wordle.
Onion?
Yeah, maybe.
Is it?
Oh, I don't know.
It could be.
Toby.
TMI is good.
TMI.
I don't think I have an A.
So no Matara.
Motto.
What?
Motora.
Not.
Bintos.
T-T-O.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
That one tickled you.
T-T-T.
That's good.
Boot, toot, toot.
Thanks, everybody.
Have you ever tried to spell attic?
I don't think.
I see.
Oh.
Wait, no.
I don't have an A.
say it again ATT I see so what do you see I feel like this
is like when the kids are like that's like advanced I come
that's really good that's really good ATT I see we both were
like what is No, wait, someone spelled Momo.
I'm ready to eat the coconut macaroon.
You did it.
Coconut macaroon time.
Oh, Nimi, it smells.
Do you wanna smell it?
Yeah, okay, I'll smell it.
Oh, it does smell pretty good.
Yeah, it smells like toasted coconut.
It tastes.
I thought it was- Even better.
Cruel, cruel.
Is it the egg in it?
Yeah, I googled it.
Oh, okay.
I'm sorry.
Macrons are actually really hard to make vegan because
they're mostly egg whites.
I'm so sorry.
I love coconut.
This is so good.
It doesn't taste like sunscreen.
No!
Not good what you mean though.
But if it did, I'd like that.
Mmm.
I'm sorry, Nimi.
I told people, okay, I would like to claim my innocence.
I did not go to the store to get with them.
So I did not...
That's all I knew, Matara.
did not check for the vegan i begged her not to buy them i
have my hands and knees after she hit her and then i had to
carry them all the way here and i made her walk way behind
me so people wouldn't wouldn't think we're together the
cruelty the cruelty i called her a curmudgeon yeah it's true
oh I thought it was like iminito or like iminin oh imininin
that's a good mom and it's all very true don't be a
curmudgeon everybody don't do it mumped mumped mumped oh
iminimid is kind of cute yeah iminim oh Everybody's still
just spelling stuff.
I love it.
It's fun!
It's the only thing we can read.
No, it's not!
Speak for yourself.
I can't read.
No.
Everybody better buy memberships so you can spell words for
us.
It's true, it's true.
Are you really going to say no to her?
After I put her through so much?
What did I go through?
Her, because she has...
Oh, yeah.
NIMI NIMI is Vintas.
Nooo!
Noob!
Oh gosh.
The memberships are rolling in!
Yay!
Oh God!
Thank you!
Thank you for the gift in!
Thank you for the gift in.
The next bottle's on mint.
No!
I love streaming on other people's channels.
It would be so silly if everybody started giving our supas
and then we're gonna make pee-pee sounds and men's gonna
have to go pee What?
What's wrong?
Oh gosh, I have to pee now you guys.
Wait, wait, they haven't started.
They haven't started.
Uh-oh Why'd you start?
I'm just preparing them.
I'm like, you know, manifesting.
Oh man.
You gotta imagine the woman you want to become.
Everybody's just saying, huh?
What are you talking about lady?
Our spa.
see manifesting manifesting our spot I'm not a part of this
here oh gosh the running water what oh god I've had so much
to drink tonight full of api juice full of api juice oh
thank you for that was so good come over juice no not yet
okay what you got like a full thing of wait where is that?
It's over there because I don't want to spill them.
Okay.
You guys are drinking your fancies.
Oh thank you!
Thank you!
I do my tiki-men voice!
It's that!
Akashupa, thank you guys.
That's pretty good.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
You should do a host stream.
Actually wait, you don't know.
So even though I'm a rebrand and go after Mint's branding.
Moi moi matadeesh, oh hiya!
She like threw her hands in the air and did that and then
looked at me all embarrassed.
I usually, I can do it on stream because I don't have people
staring you down.
We're just looking at you like.
It's my favorite thing when I do it on stream everyone's
like please stop you're hurting me us in real time yeah
literally i saw their faces drop in real time no i have to
say nimi's been very supportive i'm into it i feel like she
likes that i prank you well we're we have a maid cafe
together coming up so you gotta practice my my good oh
that's good that's good that's good my russian accent come
My Russian accent comes out when I do Japanese.
Do girls have that?
Like, well, probably not.
I haven't heard your Japanese.
Do you have like an accent that comes out a little bit or
you know?
Nihongo Deikimasen.
Oh, that's so cute.
It's so cute.
Oh, that's literally her.
That's me in Japan all the time.
Sumi Masen.
Oh, Sumi Masen.
Nihongo Deikimasen.
Wait, I have one of my best jokes ever.
I love Tsukimen, ramen,
Did you bust that one out?
She does!
She actually does!
The best was Mint going, oh, I'm like, this is...
I knew exactly what was coming.
I have Matara, well, Matane.
You did that to...
You did that at the Ace Combat event.
I did that to, like, one of the directors of Ace Combat.
It did!
And you just, after she came and spoke to them, and, like,
the most polite, kind Japanese, she was so respectful.
that up I was like I think I said I will not on it yeah you
did really loud in the lobby listen I'm scared to go to
Japan because I'm afraid I'm gonna be like what was the
thing oh I uh you I think you gave me shit cuz I would tell
people when I would leave the 7-eleven I'd be like ja ne oh
yeah she's like you can't do that it's too it's too impolite
oh that what you're cool though oh yeah you have to you have
to moonwalk out I wait I have cacoy goki booty I love it she
loves my jokes she loves them I love it keep coming there's
also like you can't spell okane without okane which is like
mom okan is like mother yeah but it's not like mother it's
not mother it's like mom like think of like mom like a
striped shirt like zebra pat and like a leopard print what
do you have no why is that your image of another i may i may
like my leopard print you need to go to osaka that would be
like your place absolutely i've been but i i've only been
there once like 14 15 are those all the photos you showed me
i remember those yeah when you go to japan though do you
like do you do you try not to talk in Japanese that much no
I do but it's mostly sumi masen I know I know sumi masen
vegan wa arimasuka I like doko desu ka my way to everything
we were when when she brought me to Disney I wanted to get
my sandwich heated up and I didn't know I should have just
like sandwich you hot though but I didn't think of it so I
was like, Atsui, Atsui.
Which means like humid.
Yeah, like the weather, yeah.
But they get it.
They get it.
But she does say, I talk like a five, because five-year-olds
do that.
They just use like whatever words they know.
But you're so extroverted that it works.
Yes.
Yeah, I guess.
And charming.
And humble.
Yes.
Oh my god, this is great.
She loves my dad jokes.
Someone finally accepts you.
Maybe it's because you're pouring me champagne.
Oh, she's just drunk, she's just drunk.
Let me get some more.
Let me get you some more.
Oh, baby.
Let me know if you want more juice as well in it.
I'll take more juice when you get more juice.
You want a mix or do you want just one?
I like the mix.
Mind, please don't stare.
We're both staring.
I'm staring at the...
You know the meme of like, everything's fine and then when
people look, you're like, Yeah, because what is that?
What is all that foam?
That's the spark.
That's the bubbles.
It's literally bubbly.
Oh, oh you're right.
Watch, she's gonna ask again.
I thought only beer did that.
Well, we have sparkling champagne.
I'm gonna top us up with a little bit of juice, because this
is like almost...
Okay.
Did we drink the whole bottle?
Well, no.
We still have, we honestly have like half a bottle in our
glasses.
Listen, I...
You do not know that you're drinking with an alcoholic pack.
woman you don't know that you're drinking with an alcoholic
hag woman I love my I'm in the middle of two alcoholic hag
women yeah yeah yeah you guys are so jealous yeah I think
what was that was that supposed to that was the tiniest
little pour no it's because I poured it before oh okay I was
gonna say why are you judging me?
I'm always judging!
No, you really do, and I love it.
I gotta judge as part of my character.
Come on, let me also wipe down a little bit.
Careful, Mimi, I poured quite a bit, so you might have to,
like, do a little slurpy first.
Okay.
A little slurpy.
I'm just kind of full.
She's ready for the slurping, everybody.
She's ready for, she's readying up for the slurping, go
downstairs I'm not gonna go to the store but I'm just gonna
go wait chat froze for real oh okay this is I was like it
did the stream die did the stream die is it time for our
last little guy oh yeah which one's that lemon lemon one of
my favorite flavors where's that from that's Miku Miku eats
a lemon was it did the cover of the shrimp song yes yeah
actually that was my alter ego but yes sorry no no no no i
wouldn't say anything no no no i'm they i'll admit it here
i'm lemon leaf no oh wait i'm so sorry no no no no no it's
not a secret it's not a secret at all i talk about every
stream i legit was like oh my god i you don't understand
over the the mouth.
I literally like the horrors of my past flashed before.
I'm like, I am going to be guillotined.
Okay, but keep the alter ego square.
Stop, stop it.
Switching subjects.
No, no, no.
Yeah.
Watermelon, lemon, watermelon.
Are you, are you mixing your, no, you didn't even eat the
macaroni?
She didn't watermelon and smelling the, I don't know what I
was doing.
I don't know why I I think the coconut and the lemon are my
top.
Vastashi was good.
The other three apricot and the, like, salted caramel were
good.
Like, I could have wouldn't have.
This just, like, that's why I was smelling them, because
this one doesn't smell like lemon to me.
Yeah, it does.
Does this smell like lemon to you?
You know, when you're a kid and somebody, like, hides you,
she would have been like, it smells like just sweet.
So that's why I was, like, smelling the other one.
The coconut smelled like coconut.
Mimi, it's so good.
Tell me it's bad.
Tell me it's terrible.
Do you have any favorite, what is it called?
Like favorite profiles for desserts.
Like what are your favorite dessert flavors?
I like fruity and vanilla.
Oh.
What kind of fruity?
Because there's like raspberry which is a little bit
different than like a blueberry or a strawberry.
I like peach.
Oh.
I like plum.
I don't like this one.
Or what?
No seed fruits?
You don't like this one?
You can have it, yeah.
Whoa.
I fed it.
it to Matala.
It tasted like, um, you know that apple, no, not apple.
Clorox wipes.
I do be sucking on Clorox with us all the time.
No, it's, it's, um, the lemon sour candy, where it's like a
very, like, artificial lemon flavor.
That's what it tastes like.
Not like a lemon.
Each, I love plum.
I love like a good plum.
Yeah, I love plum.
Stone fruits.
What?
Stone fruits?
What's that?
Not like raspberry, blueberry.
No?
No, that's fruit.
with the stone in the middle.
Oh yeah.
Like a peach and a plum.
Oh.
With those like little goose whatever they are like the
little yellow like they almost taste like tomatoes and
they're like this.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Persimmon?
No persimmon is big.
In Russian persimmon is called khaki which literally means
like many little shits.
What?
I'm not kidding khaki is like many little shits but it's
like that's how they call it.
Why would you want to eat that?
I know.
It's because like the persimmon is usually I think from like
like not in Mongolia but but like more like towards the
Asian part of of the Soviet Union so they just adopted their
word but then why did they name it that because they adopted
the local word for it I think they're from like Afghanistan
oh so like it's not meant to mean that it's not meant to
mean that no no it's like they basically yeah thank you for
explaining yeah so basically they took like they localized
the word oh it's like KHA like something like that You guys
are a bunch of khaki.
Pursimids, persimids, persimids!
Persimids!
Delicious and cute!
Oh, khaki's in Japan too, nice.
Wait, is it also khaki in Japanese?
Oh, it is khaki in Japanese.
Oh, cool.
What about yablaka malakou?
Yablaka is apple and malakou is milk.
Because, yeah, it apparently tastes bad.
What?
The yablaka malakou.
What is it?
But they, so in Metal Gear, of course, they say
yablokomoloko, but they say it with like an accent.
They say yablokomoloko, which is rhyme.
It's yablokomoloko.
They actually don't rhyme.
Yablokomoloko.
But it's so much easier to say the bluboko.
Yeah.
Yablokomoloko.
Why would you say that?
She hates us.
Okay, all of you.
I called you persimmons.
All of you that are upset at her are going to the fig room
in the maid cafe.
Mods.
Figg them out.
Figg them.
Figg out.
Figg you.
What was it?
Figg them wists and fig you too.
Figg them kids.
They're crying now.
No.
That's been, it's been making fun of me because every time
something happens I'm like, huh huh.
It's like the most, I'll be like, I can't find this thing
and she goes she was locked out of her hotel I'm like I
wasn't locked out of my hotel okay you weren't locked out of
your hotel you just made that sorry she was locked out of my
room in my home back in the Soviet Union where we lived
together in my imagination as wives must have been cold I'm
confused I'm literally I'm just dreaming up a scenario you
are yeah I must have been cold it was cold.
The room was cold actually.
Very cold.
Yeah.
Are you warmer now?
I am warmer.
Okay good.
We're under a blanket.
Yeah we are.
Are you cold?
No.
Okay.
I get fed off of teasing you.
It feeds my, it gives my soul warmth.
Hee hee hee hee.
Oh.
The chat keeps freezing.
Sorry guys.
Saw me guys.
We're like trying to read.
Are you there?
Hello.
If you can hear us, can you type booby please please hey tt
i see but i don't see i i don't see a tt oh wait they might
be like down down no does one of you have your phone close
oh wait yeah we can check the stream on phone oh they're
back they're back they're back did they hear anything did
they hear about did we disconnect or no yeah we can't tell
because the chat freezes but we don't know if it's like what
if they all collectively pranked us and like stop talking
wait they're like talking about figs though still oh I think
the I think the chat is a little delayed hold on they heard
everything okay it's working on my phone they pranked us
they pranked us you pranked us to the fig room they admitted
they're all just stopping at once being like what three two
one stop no I think it's just it's there see how smooth
Yeah, it is.
Oh my god, why didn't we think of that?
Yeah.
You're so smart.
It's true, we don't need to see someone.
We all have phones.
We have phones.
We're just silly gals, you guys.
We all got them for Diablo Immortal.
What?
I got mine for RuneScape.
Ay.
A phone?
Yeah.
It's because ages ago when Diablo, people wanted a Diablo 4.
Oh yeah, and they were like mobile.
You got phones, don't you?
Oh.
I love that.
There was that one guy that was like, is this an April
Fool's joke?
I get second-hand embarrassed, man.
I know.
But it fuels me.
I like it.
Guys have phones.
You got your phone for RuneScape?
Tell me more.
I was one of the first people in the beta when they released
Old School RuneScape on mobile in, like, 2019.
Whoa.
Is this still your routine?
You're like, you know, it's nighttime.
You get it to your bath.
RuneScape.
No, I got burnt out because I got 75 agility so that I could
go hunting.
the blue dragons to get my magic skill up but then by the
time I got 75 agility I was so tired oh you gave up you were
so close what the hell I know I know not me somebody else
hop on age of empires a yes we should we should I want to do
a stream where we try to beat the hardest level do you do
you I will do it I will do it we can I will do it.
Yeah, I want to keep like incrementing the difficulty and
try to beat the hardest computer.
Can I be on like medium but drinking?
No, I'm teasing, I'm teasing.
That's not true.
Do you have a favorite Sith that you do?
The Persians.
Because they have elephants.
They have elephants.
She's a mean machine with an elephant.
I believe it.
She is.
How is your like micro?
Not that good.
But the only way to counter the elephants is with the monks.
So the enemy has to be good at.
Yeah, so the enemy has to be good at micro.
you when it's smart if you know you're playing against us
low-level noobs you're like I will play something they can't
count it the strat I wonder what else could maybe like
catapults or when you watch like the really big pros play
they do catapult out plays we're like when when like the
other player will try to catapult they run around the
catapult so the catapults catapult themselves it's so
embarrassing it's so embarrassing yeah like imagine you
catapult yourself like how does it even happen so basically
like so okay now I'm going to illustrate it.
So the catapults.
So you, that's your catapults.
She, big, cool player.
Yeah.
Has fast whole seats.
I'm a bad player, everybody.
So you are, like, throwing your catapults here, and then you
have, like, a big army, right?
And your army is looping, and she'll loop around you so that
your army will follow her.
Oh!
And then your catapults basically kill your own army!
It's crazy!
Friendly fire!
Yeah!
I never thought about that.
And it's so embarrassing.
It's really embarrassing.
That's something I would do, you guys.
I killed Barney in Half-Life.
I could do anything.
Yeah.
Barney is in Half-Life?
Uh-huh.
He has Skippity Toilet.
He is.
He's like the main character.
I don't know why Half-Life you guys are playing.
When did you, were you into like the original Age of Empires
as well?
No, I only played Age of Empires 2.
Yeah, me too.
At the land parties.
Oh, you know what it's about?
Yeah, yeah.
I played in my dad's lap.
what the basketballs are happening one of the teams that was
in the playoffs the spurs I thought it was I thought it was
hockey well there's there's the basketball just happened
hockey just happened oh wait what about the football wait
yeah it's a soccer yeah it's a year of sport year of sport
guys sport is happening all it was so I think it was the San
Antonio Spurs they have a photo of them in a private jet in
like 1999 but they're all like in their private jet and the
other computers versus each other playing Starcraft one
that's And they're doing duels on Starcraft 1 and they're
like fighting each other.
It's really silly.
Do you guys know what I'm talking about?
Peace between the nerds and the jock.
Yeah.
Exactly.
In their private jet.
Yeah, you just have to be rich and then you can be a nerd or
a jock or whatever.
Do you have any interest in playing Age of Empire 1?
Is it better than 2?
No, Age of Empire 2 is the best.
But Age of Empire 1, it's like silly.
Like when you visit, it's silly mechanics.
so much less customization there's like less sieves and they
have less unit but it's kind of fun because like like for
example the boats they just look like little like logs like
your guy your your dude is just a shirtless guy with like a
wooden club oh I only monkey mode I only built them as a kid
oh that's that's the way you pick one unit and you know it's
because they were shirtless with a club but Tara knew who
she was from a very early age she getting off on like 5
pixels.
That's crazy.
On the edge of Empires 1.
Hey, you guys are judging me.
All of them with infested Kerrigan.
Don't even.
You guys did the same thing.
All of you guys with Cortana's 3 pixels.
You're yelling at a dead chat.
Crazy stuff.
Okay, should be.
Should be.
Should be mad.
Hello.
Sorry, my OBS crashed.
I got mad and I turned everything off.
I was like, I'm done.
I got drunk I yelled I think it might be a sugar hive that's
why the macaroons all hit me all at once nothing to do with
the Prosecco a little bit a little bit of this a little bit
of column a little bit of column B a little bit of column C
which is Gamer Age.
Ugh.
We're back.
Not about that.
What other games do y'all remember?
Because you said RuneScape, I want to get back to that
conversation.
Did you have a favorite skill to skill and a least favorite
skill to skill?
Honestly, I played, like, as an adult on the remake of Old
School.
Oh, that's awesome.
Well, I played as a kid, but I didn't know what was
happening.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because you're, like, doing random stuff.
But I really just trained agility to 75 and then and then
suffering the whole week what about agility was like you're
like this is mine you need 75 agility to get the shortcut to
get to the blue dragons and the blue dragons are the fastest
way to train your magic oh but also to do magic you have to
do the rune running which is also very tedious that people
just pay money to get other people to do it not legally but
you know what i mean you know if it works it works yeah But
I was listening to podcasts.
I was listening to like true crime podcasts and like
training my agility.
That is something you both have so in common.
Mint loves.
I do.
I listen to it sometimes.
Okay.
Maybe I'm maybe I'm exaggerating.
I'm like these are her favorites.
She loves it more.
Because you always know everything about crime podcasts.
No?
Maybe I'm wrong.
I know about true crime.
Sorry, it's my other girlfriend.
Oh.
Who is she thinking of?
No.
I know I like I enjoy true crime stuff though.
I do listen to that kind of stuff.
into like any of it it freaks me out no i had to quit
because i felt too bad that it was like true i wish i would
make fake fake right yeah like those like fake like
paranormal but the radio stuff like yeah yeah like it's
radio shows but they're like oh this is actually happening
in the universe of this radio show yeah yeah but true crime
fake exactly yeah exactly i think i've least one person does
that now.
But I don't I don't know their YouTube channel.
There's probably quite a few that do some kind of like
fantasy or something but still yeah.
But I want it to be like realistic.
I want to know how they decapitate him.
Do you know that TikTok audio that's like his arms were cut
off, his legs were cut off.
She's the one that showed that to me.
I always quote it because it's so funny.
I started quoting it because of her.
Her legs were cut off.
Her fingers were cut off.
oh yeah i just realized i'm standing behind you so
menacingly you are why did you turn off the chat by the way
because i think it broke obs oh because it was i think it
was too fast yeah now i can admire your new archive oh no oh
no congrats on all the the collabs it's it's been crazy
because i remember you like went to the pop-up and you've
been a fan for I know I even have the same figure I remember
when we were in Japan, I bought the same figure as you Oh,
yeah, yeah.
It's the lady that you collab with yeah, yeah, yeah, the
Arona Erona.
Yeah, Arona.
Yeah.
I know she's so cute though.
She's really cute.
I have her on my shelf.
You're like one of those people that just collects it
because it's cute.
Yeah, well it's because that's valid.
It's a memory of like when we were in Japan and we went to
that pop-up together and then it got we got rained on.
We got rained on.
Yeah, yeah.
It was crazy.
So see what I mean like now I like instantly lock it into
like my mind palace.
Not the mind palace.
So that's how I remember it.
No, I felt I would want to collect figures from things that
I didn't know.
But I felt bad.
But now like a lot of artists release figures and they're
cute.
And so I just collect those because I'm like, oh well, I
like this artist.
And it's not always an original character.
I like cute thing.
I like my cute thing.
And I love having matching stuff.
Mint knows this.
I love having matching stuff.
We could have matching bags.
We are.
Mint bought me a bag today.
because she thinks my old bag is stinky.
You said that yourself.
You're like, it's time to hang up the bag.
When we were in Japan ages ago, we went to a brand she
really likes and I got us these matching Miffy bags.
But mine is like, it's looking pretty rough.
I saw it last time and I was like, oh, Miffy's like all like
matted.
Because it's got like white puffies and Miffy bunnies on it
and they got like...
It's pretty bad.
Oh wait, I've seen your version.
Mine is like that, but like, Rebbit.
Zombie Miffy.
Moldy, Miffy.
Just like the moldy mommos.
Yeah, I've got to send you that bag.
Yes, Mint's got good bags.
I'm trying to steal Mint's bag, too.
I'm trying to give it to her.
She likes it.
I want to give it.
Why do you do you like this?
Do you like this please?
Please.
It's really old though, so.
Really?
That bad?
Yeah, this one.
I'm old?
I've had it forever.
No way.
Just steal it.
You could.
You could steal it.
I'm in my stealing era.
I'm in my villain era.
And then I would always look at it and think of you.
Yeah.
You're like, oh look at that.
I stole that.
Yeah.
I'll be like, where'd that go?
So weird my bag went missing after that day.
So it's funny, like some people when they get drunk, they
like change completely.
And like it, for me, for example, I just become like really
annoying more.
But I'm very where I'm like, oh my god, I love you so much,
no, no, no, when I'm really drunk.
So for you, you can become klepto.
Oh, klepto drunk.
You're like, oh, I took this, I took this, I took this.
You steal the blanket.
Usually I'm a happy drunk, which is like the dangerous.
Why?
Well, because then I enjoy it too much.
Oh, the klepto?
No, no.
I enjoy drinking too much, because it makes me happy, which
is, that's dangerous.
That's true, that's true.
I'm never happy.
What?
Maybe I need to...
Because you never drink.
I know.
I'm going to say, maybe I need to pick up drinking.
No, no.
Don't do it.
Give me the cup.
Give me the...
Wait, I wonder if it's so bubbly that...
No, you can't.
It's bubbly.
Wait, you're going to die.
You know how much of my spit is probably in that?
Because I kept like sipping it and then back and then
sipping it in the back.
And then the giant watermelon in there.
I put a little watermelon slice in mine so that it...
It actually is not...
so bubbly, but I think if I kept more of my spit?
No.
But if I kept drinking him, I think my tummy would hurt.
You know what else we make of him here?
Matara just threatened violence!
She just said... She made a fist.
She's gonna punch me in the stomach.
I gotta live like Success Kid.
Yes, yes.
The solar plexus is where she gonna get me.
No, I wouldn't.
She would.
I'd do it here because it's more fatal.
What?
I'm a ghost.
No, I hate to say salt.
Yeah, salt me in the neck.
Oh, my God.
That sounds gross.
A little salt as a treat.
Yummy.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
If I bring an EMF reader near you, is it just going to be
like, ee?
Probably.
Ee.
I don't know.
I can't go really high.
My voice is really low.
I can't.
You sound like a dolphin?
You do.
Yeah.
You should try communicating with them.
This is what she means when she gets more annoying.
I kind of like it though.
I'm kind of into it.
Stop gassing me up.
I could listen to this.
I'm not used to this.
Wait, you're getting new ASMR info right here.
This is actually great.
Like ASMR.
It goes red on the back.
It does.
Oh my God.
someone said you're an enabling drunk i am i just i just
like everything when i drink everything's awesome everything
is awesome everything is awesome i love it yeah yeah maybe
you should start drinking i'm gonna become an alcoholic yeah
no no you're supposed to be that yeah you know now you What
about her happiness?
Is that not important to you?
Oh, okay, okay.
No!
But what can you drink that's flat?
Oh, dang, I'm gonna get the hard liquor.
You know, vodka and orange juice is a screwdriver.
A screwdriver.
I think tequila sunrise is like tequila, orange juice, and a
little bit of grenadine, so it's gonna be like pain.
I've heard to stay away from tequila, though.
That's what everybody says.
Tequila's delicious.
Did your grandma say that?
I don't know.
Wait, did my grandma say that?
I love that woman.
May she rest in peace.
Oh my god, need me.
I have to tell you those stories.
So I went to Min's house for Thanksgiving.
It was a great time.
I met her family.
I met her grandma.
She was lovely.
Yeah.
And then we both got a little bit busy.
And then we were doing a collaborative catch.
I'm like, how's your grandma?
She's like, what?
And she's like, she died on street.
And I'm like, and I legitimately think, like, you see how we
are?
So I'm like, you thought it was a joke.
I'm like, no, come on.
I'm just like, no, she's fine.
I was like, it was like a couple days that you, like a
before that you had asked to, so it's really bad.
Well, the thing is, like, we have caught up, like, a few
days before that, but we got caught up about, like,
completely different stuff, right?
Like, you know how it is sometimes with friends.
Well, I'm also not just gonna be like, oh, by the way.
By the way.
Remember my grandma?
But also, what am I supposed to say on the, everybody, if
they saw me talk about it, then they knew.
But if I was like, oh, she's good.
You can say she's at peace.
She's at peace.
And I, I legit, like, oh, I don't know.
No, no, she's at peace.
She lived a great life.
She's at peace.
She's good.
She's phenomenal.
She was a little devil.
I want to be like that in 10 years.
I think, though, if she went to hell, she'd be commander
down there.
She'd be commander.
She'd be number two to Satan.
Yeah.
In, like, the best way.
Genuinely.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's fast, too.
Moving up the ladder quick.
Yeah.
Corporate takeover.
Yeah, like...
cool well she has experience in games so it's like she'll
use that experience to this is all stuff she said on stream
before by the way this real yeah yeah actually okay for real
for real we're not trolling you this is actually real she
used her like gang experience to climb up the ranks of level
100 mafia box i can't believe i was watching your stream and
you were like guys what do i post on this picture and i was
like i was like well she's gonna ask her chat and be really
slow about it I'm just she posted the pic first I took a
really cool picture of like little mint in the back of like
this party bus kind of it was weird it was yeah cool wait I
think I saw that yeah guys please like don't steal this help
me caption and then she just posts it it was my photo to be
fair I took it no I took that photo that I posted they're
fighting they're fighting we're gonna start slapping each
other this is how every they're fighting they're They're
kissing, they're kissing, they're fighting, they're
fighting, they're kissing again?
Yeah.
I think the chat wants us to fight.
Pillow fight.
Tozies.
Meet.
Time.
Oh, God.
Everyone has to put on the stinging eye mask.
Oh, oh, yeah.
1,000 needles stinging eye mask.
We gotta get you into those.
It's like the blinding stew.
With the blinding stew.
If you take it, it's three days of blindness.
That's why you give to the children who are bad.
Is that in a video game?
Where's that from?
No, it's real.
It's real.
Oh, is it?
Oh my God.
Have you girls seen there's something on TikTok?
They call it the Everlasting Stew or something like that.
Wait, what's the Everlasting Stew?
It's literally like somebody will boil like whatever soup.
And then instead of like, you know, you finish it, you throw
it out.
They just, it gets low.
They just put water.
Oh, I have heard of that.
And they keep like reboiling.
Apparently because it never stops boiling, it like doesn't
go bad.
Oh.
Freaks me out.
That's what medieval peasants were eating from thousands of
people.
But they also had a life expectancy of like, I know this is
why they had dysentery like I would not be alive perpetual
stew that's what they're saying I watched that guy on
YouTube shorts 500 year old stew it reminds me of the bread
the the like you make the starter of the bread and then it
get like the sourdough yeah sourdough that's what it kind of
that's true sourdough also lives forever yeah what yeah
having a pet you have to feed it and it okay is it the same
as kombucha the scoopy i think it's called it like you have
to like make it eat they're both fermented yeah yeah it's
similar i think they might even both be yeasts oh that makes
sense somebody look it up please are they both yeast are
they yeast yeast bread pet that's good it's kind of cute
yeah but like you open the jar and it's like moving and like
no it is the whole no no well mine wasn't but mine might
have been dead oh god you're you're i don't think you're a
you're a nurse of death it reminds me of like an alien thing
i'm a victorian nurse oh more like leeches yeah yeah what is
it called amputation yeah i think you're humors lobotomy oh
my god yeah you're like classic
I think about that how apparently in medieval times
everybody was always because it was so unsafe to drink water
that everybody drank like really low alcohol yeah everybody
was living it up everybody was buzzed I'm like damn that's a
life I want to have was your was your wait hold on dober is
that what his name is I had dober and then I had dober to
and they both failed mysterious circumstances I don't know
what happened the leeches I'm gonna try Dobert 3 though.
Dobert 3?
Or Dobert Jr. Triplet.
Maybe he should be Dobert Jr. Maybe he'll have a better life
expectancy.
No, children are always the first to go.
That's why they have like 10 of them.
You're right.
The Scarlet Fever or something's gonna come out.
You should eventually like do, cause you know they do like
electric boogaloo and stuff.
Like you should eventually have like Dobert 3.
Bread balloon.
No, that's the rhyme with 3, you dingus.
Oh.
Oh sorry.
Jubilee.
Yeah.
Number three.
Fantastic.
Bread believe.
Bread believe is good.
Bread believe everybody.
Bread believe.
Yeah.
Dobert the third will succeed.
I'm glad they believe in me.
They do.
Oh my gosh.
Red third also kind of makes it sound more regal like he is
bound to be a king.
That's true.
Yeah.
He can't die.
No, no bless oblige.
to be a noble yeah yeah i like that a lot are they are they
sorry we're getting like involved in your bread family we're
like i'm invested i'm so invested i need some motivation to
kill another bread no to create another bread life life you
create a life to wait how do you start a start sourdough
yeah put flour and water together and then you leave it in
the world and it collects yeast from the air, from the
environment, wild.
What if a wasp flies into it?
Then you have to throw it away.
There's a fig, a fig sourdough.
What if in your sourdough you put a little fig and then a
wasp comes in, no?
Then you throw it all away.
Do you actually have to?
What, if a bug goes in your food?
Bugs are, what's wrong with bugs?
She's vegan.
Oh.
That's the only thing stopping me from eating a wasp.
From eating my beautiful claws.
My claws, I don't know if you see them.
They kind of look like a crab claws, so.
Well, crabs are just big bugs.
Yeah, they are.
But yeah, you heard it here first.
It's her veganism stopping her from cannibalizing my body.
You'd be the goner.
I'm going to chop you up and put you on fear factor.
No.
The people have to eat you.
And you just eat me.
I'm not going to go there.
I want to eat this.
Like, you eat Momo.
what's the difference they're delicious okay but what about
them what makes you what does that make you delicious okay
nutritious okay humble we've already said that twice this
time just in case you forget i haven't yeah delicious
nutritious i have to go to the bathroom okay we can mute
don't listen yeah let's mute let's mute because i'll give it
to unmute no i think i'll be quiet
I'll turn the noise gate on.
They're not going to hear.
Well, not if I go into the microphone.
I like that she likes my jokes.
I like that it makes you miserable.
My Oshi likes my nemesis jokes.
Wait, that's so funny.
That's so good.
That sounds like a light novel or something.
My Oshi likes my nemesis.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My O-no, my Oshi laughs at my nemesis as jokes about me.
About- Because it'd have to be like the longest title ever,
right?
They're not about me, though.
You have to, I guess, make jokes about me.
We were making jokes about you the whole time.
We have been?
Was it someone?
What do you mean?
Wait, guys, well then we'd have to start teasing me and
stuff.
Oh my god, I'm like, I'm down to that.
What do you mean, you guys?
Teasing me.
That's so crazy.
What do you mean you're teasing me?
Wait, are we actually?
Are we actually teasing me?
Oh, that was like a good piece.
Uh-huh.
Hee-hee.
We're having a pineapple, everybody.
It's going to eat our mouths.
Mm-hmm.
Whoa, whoa.
It was a good pineapple.
I really wanted to buy cherries.
I think it would have been funny.
I love that vibe.
Very funny.
And your Oshi would have laughed.
Your Oshi would have laughed if that had happened.
Muted it?
Muted?
No, no.
She just put the noise gated thing.
It was muted the whole time, everybody.
We're thinking of like a light novel name of like, so you
are her Oshi, surprise.
She talks about it.
But like, my Oshi liked my nemesis' jokes about me.
That kind of thing, yeah.
right it could be like enemies to lovers kind of thing who's
gonna be the lovers oh not happening sorry I have wives but
like in a platonic way I'm making stuff out no it should be
it should be enemies to haters to nemesis it already what's
a more than a hater than an enemy okay haters to enemies to
nemesis to sisters sister what Nimmy does not approve.
She rejects.
Well, once you go to sisters, you can never go to lovers
again.
Yeah.
I don't think...
Nobody's trying to go to lovers.
I don't think Vittara was the lover's part.
See, guys, she hates me.
Which one?
You.
Oh, I mean, yeah.
Yeah.
How does she get bitten?
Oh, I don't know how long stream has been.
because oh yeah we had to stop oh an hour ago because it was
6 30.
i am going off of you guys i'm chilling if you need me to
yap i'm yapping if you need me to go downstairs and get
another little bottle 70 minutes thank you guys 70 minutes
that's really generous i do have some work to do but i can't
wait if we want to keep talking Yeah, but...
We definitely got like a sugar crush from the singing.
You're gonna sing?
La la la la la.
You should sing something.
We can.
You should sing Lips of an Angel.
It's a really good song.
Is that Nickelback?
No, but close.
You can sing Nickelback.
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
Lips of an Angel is a song by Hinder and the guy literally
goes, Honey, why you call it?
Like, me.
Is that not Nickelback?
That is, uh, someday, somehow, gonna make it all right, but
not right now.
Or, um, what's the other one?
Look at this graph, this graph.
Every time I'll do it makes me laugh.
Yeah, the list of an angel, he literally is like, I don't
know what you're calling me.
I thought that was Nickelback.
They're like both dad music songs.
So rock bands weren't making a lot of money in the early
2000s, so when Nickelback made so much money, a lot of those
rock bands kind of like did the whole bravado rock of.
Oh.
Yeah.
You want to sing?
Yes.
What do you want to sing?
I love it.
Yeah.
Will you sing with me?
Yeah, we'll sing with me.
We'll sing.
I'll sing along.
I need them.
Trust me and I say this with love, Nimi, you do not want to
start having me sing.
Do you know how I sing?
No, no, no.
It's because I'm literally going to sing, my old co-worker
used to say, I sing depressive songs from the 1900s.
Wait, but you won't be able to hear the music.
No, we'll just play it on the phone.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Guys are playing it from the phone.
This is how I do my online voice lessons.
Really?
I can just play it on my phone.
Wait, that's so good.
What do you want to sing?
I don't know.
Lips of an angel.
She picked my song.
I didn't suggest one.
But she would have
Did I made you like start?
Yes!
Well I knew it but then I was like singing it and I was like
oh this is funny.
This is the happiest moment of my life that they're all
gonna suffer.
I'm sure if you heard it right now you'd instantly recognize
it.
Wait no that's coming from the lips of an angel hearing
those words it makes me weak.
Yes, yes.
And I don't want to say goodbye.
make it hard to be faithful with lips of an angel how did we
both get it oh yeah this is so exciting oh wait you have to
crank that honey why are you calling me oh sorry I thought
he started he did oh wait hold on so late I can't see on
your phone sorry I have a privacy screen we can use mine
okay sorry wait how did my phone get your oh she doesn't
even want to use your phone she hates me she hates me you
got your phone is grimy never meet your heroes they even
have the the app that you surely pay for so no the app this
one oh caravan yeah yeah she's paying for it i have an
account so i need me too me three oh my we're giving them
like 150 a month so we are gonna sing this damn curry okay
okay guys sorry you're gonna get demonetized oh i don't care
oh my god i'm so ready i'm gonna sing it to my fork yeah i'm
gonna sing it to my fork honey why are you calling me so
late you're kind of singing it's kind of hard it's all right
now it sounds like a sign off honey why are you crying is
every thing Oh, it was all red.
I gotta whisper because it can't be too loud.
I'll turn it down.
Because my girl's in the next room.
Sometimes I wish she was you.
I guess we never really moved on.
It's really good to hear your voice.
Say my name.
sweet coming from the lips of an angel hearing those words
it makes me weak and i never want to say goodbye but girl
you make it hard to be faithful with the lips of an angel
I'm so happy.
You guys can hear the BGM.
It's funny.
Imagine they're like, no, it's muted.
It's like me.
Wait, why?
Is there BGM play?
This one.
What's that one?
And yes, I've dreamt of you too.
Oh, is there a BGM play?
Does he know you're talking to me with a star guy?
No, I don't think she has a clue.
Well, my girl's in the next room.
Sometimes I wish she was you.
I guess I ain't never really moved on.
It's really good to hear your voice saying my name.
It sounds so sweet.
Coming from the lips of an angel.
Hearing those words, it makes me weak.
What if
I stab you but I didn't imagine with a plastic cord or I'll
survive with your nursing skills you Oh my god imagine if I
like overshot it a little or like true it's a plastic cord
I'm stronger I'm stronger than a plastic cord I don't know
about that I handed her my fork microphone talking to it
while addressing the chat.
It's really good to hear your voice.
Say my name, it sounds so sweet.
Coming from the lips of an angel.
Hearing those words, it makes me witty.
And I never want to say goodbye.
But girl, you make it hard to be faithful.
Are you sure you don't record?
We have an extra one.
The lips of an angel.
Goodbye, but girl, you make it hard to be faithful.
All of us are holding up our fork microphones.
We should post a photo of just the forks after this.
is like all chewed on honey why are you calling me solely oh
my god that made me so happy that made me so happy i can die
happy that was good let's do another one yeah what does
anybody have any requests it's your guys's turn oh is the
stream even on It is!
It is!
They just mute it off.
They're like, I'm out of this shit.
I don't need it on.
Nickelback!
Ooh, I'm down.
You guys need to get this visual.
We are sitting on the floor with a blanket.
Yeah.
Holding forks.
About to get a noise complaint.
Yeah, probably.
It's too early.
They don't noise complain until 10.
Okay, okay, okay.
Loveful.
Okay.
That's a kiss.
Love me.
Yeah.
Fool me!
Go on!
And fool me!
God!
Dear, I fear we're facing a problem.
You love me no longer.
I know that maybe there is nothing that I can do to make you
do.
Mama tells me I shouldn't bother.
that I ought to stick to another man, a man that surely
deserves me.
But I think you do.
And so I cry, I pray, and I beg.
Love me, love me, say that you love me.
Fool me, fool me, go on and fool me.
Love me, love me, pretend that you love me.
Need me, need me, just say that you need me So I cry And I
beg for you to love me, love me Say that you love me, need
me, need me Just say that you need me I can't care about
anything but you me I have desperately pondered spent my
nights awake and I wonder what I could have done in another
way to make you say sorry I'm not using you without the work
solution I will end up lost in confusion I don't care if you
really long as you don't go.
And so I cry, I pray and I beg.
Love me, love me, say that you love me.
Fool me, fool me.
Go on and fool me.
Love me, love me.
Pretend that you love me.
Knee me, knee me.
Just say that you need me.
And so I cry.
And I beg for you to love me, love me Say that you love me,
need me, need me Just say that you need me, I can't give up
anything but you Anything but you Love me, love me, say that
you love me Fool me, fool me Go on and fool me Love me, love
me I know that you're nimby I can't care about anything but
you
Dude, the fork?
I'm stimming.
It's working.
You feeling the fork?
Yeah.
Fork, yeah.
Fig yeah.
Fig no.
Wait, no, fig yeah.
yeah we want things send the width to the figs to the figs
to the figs oh please don't pick snake eater it's really
hard to sing no i was gonna pick nickelback okay which one
though hmm what do you think photograph is the one
photograph is the one but uh someday is also a really really
known one saving me there's also like yeah yeah i want to be
a rock star photograph.
All right.
Look at this girl.
And then in between songs.
Look at this photograph.
Every time I do it makes me laugh.
How did I guys get so red?
And what the hell is on my Torah's head?
It's a homo.
This is where I grew up.
I think the present owner fakes it up.
I never knew we went out.
down down.
I can't.
Second floor is high for sneaking out.
And this is why I went to school.
Most of the time I had better things to do.
Criminal record says I've broken twice.
I must have done it half a dozen times.
I wonder if it's too late.
Should I go back and try to graduate?
Life is better now than it was back then.
If it was them I wouldn't let me in.
Oh God, I...
Every memory of looking out the back door I had the photo
album spread out on my bedroom floor It's hard to say it,
hard to say it Goodbye, goodbye Every memory of walking out
the front door I found the photo of a friend that I was
looking for It's hard to say it, time to say it Goodbye,
goodbye.
Is this you on the stream?
Oh, are we on the stream?
No, it was a joke.
We could.
Because closing time is always a banger.
Closing.
Time.
Do-do-do.
Remember the old arcade, blew every dollar that we ever
made.
The cops hated us hanging out.
They say somebody went, I'm burning it down.
We used to listen to the radio and sing along with every
song we know.
We said so bad we thought oh how it feels.
To sing with more than just the steering wheel.
Kim's the first girl I kissed.
I was so nervous that I missed.
She's had a couple of kids since then.
I haven't seen her since God knows where.
No, whoa, whoa.
Die.
Every memory of looking out the back door.
I had the photo album spread out on the bathroom floor.
It's hard to say it.
Time to say it.
Goodbye.
Every memory of walking out the front door.
I found the photo of the friend that I was looking for.
It's hard to say it.
Time to say it.
Goodbye.
we sound good yeah you know i was gonna say i kind of
understand why people hate nickelbacks i was thinking the
same thing i was thinking the same thing i was like it's
just the same line over and over every song is the same i'm
missing now i don't know now i can't believe it so hard to
stay to leave it.
If I could relive those days, I know one thing that would
never change.
Change, change.
Every memory I'm looking out the back door, I have the photo
album spread out on my bedroom floor.
It's hard to say it, it's hard to say it.
Goodbye, goodbye.
Every memory I'm walking out the front door, I found the
photo of the friend that I was looking for.
it's hard to say it it's hard to say it goodbye goodbye oh
every time I do it makes me laugh every time I do it makes
me laugh what does it make him I they got a lot of hate
because every song just sounded the same but also they found
the winning formula they really did I'm get it I get it and
I love like 10 of their songs.
Yes, they sound like game and I confuse them all the time,
but I love them.
I'm sorry, but as a Nirvana fan, a lot of Nirvana songs
sound very similar as well.
That's fair.
Maybe this one, it kind of like just grates on you by like
the scene.
You're just like, it was a different time, okay?
I can see why someone would be like, oh yeah, it hits me in
the heart.
In the Kokoro.
Yeah, in the Kokoro.
Kim's the first girl I kissed too.
I just came out of nowhere.
It's like, who's Kim?
Who's Kim?
What if it was actually like Patricia and Patricia's like,
what the fuck?
Chad?
Yes.
What do you mean?
I always knew you had a thing for Kim.
Hmm.
That was fun.
Kim.
Good times.
How did you guys like it?
Did we sound good?
Doug.
Drew.
Did we sound good?
i bit off a part of my fork because i was like you bit off
part of your fork you were into it i was into it yeah
probably the sound was a little funky but it sounded good no
way they're so nice they're so nice you guys are nice minto
do you want more oj yes please mimi how do you feel if i go
back to a small bottle it's like half a glass i won't say no
i'll use that minto did you want a little mix again yes
please yeah I got you cookie but Matara's being my bartender
she's making me a cocktail of mango juice and orange I'm
gonna be so full of vitamin C I'm gonna be so healthy oh
you're actually going yeah it's not far and I'm gonna get a
small one just don't worry okay obviously I know not leaving
my room you But just in case, you guys, like, Mimi can
choose how much she drinks, all that good stuff.
Don't worry.
I'm an adult legally.
And for a long time, I have been.
And she's an unlicensed nurse.
Or license.
It depends on which day it is.
Which license?
License to kill.
You need one of those, like, just carton, like, carton
paper.
And it's a carton.
How do you say it?
Like, um, plastic, not plastic.
it's like brown box cardboard box you need one of those
things and it's like licensures yeah like you need like 20
different ones so if people ask you literally can be like
you just cycle through them like business cards yes yeah i
have this license and this license and they can all be for
like different weird stuff license for leeches oh yeah a
license to have my leech license leech license very
important oh my goodness now my perfumes oh so i got this
one because it's a cheaper version of the other perfume that
i have but it's actually really really nice then i have this
very fancy one that i love did you spray this one earlier no
i like this wait i'm gonna take a picture sure this is nice
and then this is the other one is a little bit pricey but
it's really nice feel free to spray it it lasts like all day
they kind of smell a little bit like brown though but I like
it's a cute bottle it is a really cute bottle yeah I'm gonna
spray it yeah go ahead you're gonna come back your naplings
are gonna be like you smell different what is this a Bobo
naplings gonna get confused like I don't know what what's
going on I stole my perfume from Rihanna is it Killian yes
yeah also this one I also use use this one on the other oh
this one smells like baby powder a little bit baby it smells
fresh yeah but like baby powder just a little bit a little
bit i like that though oh and i'm gonna grab makes your
bottom feel good your bottom oh yeah this one's more like
i'm bad it's more citrusy yeah that's i think that that's i
think that's why i like that one are you mixing them i'm
mixing i'm mixing imagine.
Smells so good in my room now guys.
Smells like girl.
Do you want to sing a song?
Whoa are we gonna sing more?
What do you want to sing?
Why not?
Okay.
What else are we gonna do?
Someone said Nimmy is Rihanna.
Is this true?
I wish.
We'll sing a Rihanna song.
Oh.
I don't know which one.
I think I only know like umbrella.
There's a, oh that one's so hard to it to me i'll be i'll be
jz and you'll be you'll be rihanna okay i'll be rihanna
you're jz wait we're actually okay good oh uh-huh uh-huh oh
yeah rihanna good girl gone bad take three action oh no
clouds in my stones let it rain i hide your plane in the
bank coming down with Jones when the clouds come we gone.
We rock a fellow, we fly higher than the weather in G5s or
better.
You know me in anticipation for precipitation.
Snackships for the rainy day.
J.
Rain Man is back with Little Miss Sunshine.
Rihanna, where you at?
You hammer and we'll never be worlds apart.
Maybe in magazines.
But you'll still be my star.
Fair because in the dark you Jesse's shining stars with you,
I'll always share.
Because when the sun shines, we shine together.
Told you I'll be here forever.
Said I'll always be your friend.
Took an oath, I'ma stick it out till the end.
Now that it's raining more than ever.
Now that we'll still grab each other.
You can stand under my umbrella.
Under my umbrella, Ella, Ella, A, A, A, under my umbrella,
Ella, Ella, A, A, A, Under my umbrella, Ella, Ella, A, A, A,
Under my umbrella, Ella, Ella, A, A, A, A, A, A, A, These
fancy things will never come in between You're a part of my
entity, I'm here for infinity.
You're part of my entity.
When the war has took its part, when the world has dealt its
cards, if the hand is hard, we'll mend your heart.
This is you losing your $50 in black.
Yes, yes.
Told you I'll be here forever.
Said I'll always be your friend.
Took an oath, I'ma stick it out till the end.
Now that it's raining more than ever, that we'll still have
each other.
You can stand under my umbrella.
Ella, Ella, A, A.
Under my umbrella.
Ella, Ella, A, A, A.
Ella, Ella, A, A, A, A.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I don't know this part.
My arms, it's okay, don't be alarmed.
Come into me.
There's no distance in between.
Our love.
Gonna let the rain pour.
I'll be all you need and more.
Because when the sun shines, we'll shine together.
Oh, we still have each other.
Oh, you do stand on the right shoulder.
Whenever we all that will still have each other, you can
stand under my umbrella.
You can stand under my umbrella.
under my umbrella, Ella, Ella, hey, hey, hey, under my
umbrella, Ella, hey, hey, hey, hey, under my umbrella, Ella,
Ella, hey, hey, hey, under my umbrella, Ella, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, baby,
come into me, Come into me.
It's raining, raining.
That is not a small bottle.
That is not a mini bottle.
I didn't have any smaller ones.
That's a big bottle.
We don't have to finish it.
What am I gonna do?
Legit, you don't have to finish it.
I'm sorry, I didn't have a smaller bottle.
I do have a smaller bottle.
I made it.
A likely story.
A lie.
Since I just went to the No Doubt concert.
sorry let's not sing no doubt songs are actually pretty
tough i like which ones do i like i like no doubt i like new
bathwater just a girl just a girl yeah that's a classic oh
don't don't don't speak oh don't speak did they pour that
yes of course it's their most they bathwater new spider okay
uh what was the other one spiderwebs please don't stop
pretending These pants are a little too big, so I keep like
pulling them.
Your butt is like in my face.
Yeah, you like it.
I can't believe you knew Rihanna's perfume, like frame one.
I'm big on fragrances.
Oh my gosh.
I used Black Orchid for the longest time because when it was
like one of Tom Ford's favorite perfumes that he did in Tom
Ford.
And I started using it again.
I started using it again, girls.
I started using again.
I'm like a fragrance baby.
I bought the Liana one because every celebrity was like,
Liana smells so good.
That's what I heard too.
Yeah.
And I was like, well, I want to smell like Rihanna.
Do you like it or is it like, do you like, because I think
it's a gourmand.
Yeah, I like the gourmands.
I also recently got like a Killian, like sample set.
And I like- That's what I always do.
Yeah, I like Angel Share and I like Princess.
We were talking about the, the subscription boxes yesterday
yeah but i was thinking of doing the perfume one that's
smart yeah i mean you can't just tell online yeah you gotta
smell it they'll say like the the notes but i don't know
anything what you do is you go to a sephora and you spray it
on yourself but then hear me out you walk with it through
the day oh yeah exactly and then you kind of feel like oh is
this my vibe is it not my vibe yeah well because i didn't
like the love don't be shy at first when i sprayed it but
then when i put it on and i wore it for a while you gotta
like live with it a little bit know you do you do you do you
do i'm sorry i'm uh getting us all drunk i am so wasted yeah
i like them wait let me take a picture take a photo took a
photo of the wine let me take a photo this one like i said i
i love this one but it's kind of expensive so i never bring
my big bottle i'm always scared they're gonna throw it out
at the airport oh yeah i bought like this one at like travel
size and a lot more i like that one it smells like a baby
like a baby what was that thing like you oh it's you smell
like a baka oh you smell like a baka erin yeager yeah you
don't remember that meme it was like you smell like a baka
erin yeager it was like a tick tock thing it was it was she
was too busy playing runescape i was dang it you weren't on
the tick on the talk on the on the talks on the ticks on the
talk no i got way too addicted to you YouTube shorts
recently, so I'm like trying to stop your addiction.
What are some of the worst shorts that you've seen?
What kind of shorts are you watching?
No, they're not bad.
It's like a lot of no, it's a lot of food and fashion
mostly.
So I've watched like movies in parts.
No, no.
I already don't watch a lot of movies because I don't like
watching them alone.
And now there's so many movies that I'm never going to see
because I watch like 13 parts of it on TikTok.
And it always has like bad doving over it.
I'm like, it is what it is.
What's been your favorite movie you've watched?
I don't know.
There's always like some like random like 80s film or
something.
So it's just kind of fun.
I don't know.
Have you girls seen Obsession?
No, I get it.
I want to.
We should go.
I can't, but your girls should watch it.
You can.
Right now.
Yeah.
Let's see if there's any listings in the area.
I want to see the drama.
too with Robert Panson I heard about that in Zendaya I just
love that like all these indie movies we were talking a
little bit before about like publishing indie and stuff like
that all these indie movies because before in order to make
a movie you have to like make a movie get a big director get
a big studio who told you I don't want this actor I want
this right right yeah and now you're actually getting indie
movies get made on you know it's on a low budget but like
two million for a movie is nothing compared to the 250
million and and they're breaking records and shouting and
it's so awesome it really feels like indies are on the i
mean we also feel it but it's really original stories are
like people are craving them i think everyone's done with
like i want to see the back room me too yeah do you see it
no i'm very bad at scary movies but i just feel like i kind
of have to suck it up because this is like iconic summer of
like two small movies really and not just them but like
multiplier's movie is obsession small obsession is like an
indie movie i didn't know that i didn't know that the reason
also why it's so kind of like monumental is because it's a
really small movie by like a guy who never directed before
random act not random but like actors who never had a big
break yeah yeah and this movie is shattering records and now
they're everywhere i didn't know that you had heated rivalry
which was also like a crave which was like a canadian random
like thing and then yeah yeah i think you would scream an
obsession i would that's one thing by the way i have to warn
you i get spooked really easily she screams i'm not even
doing that to be embarrassing like i just literally even
like my roommate sometimes if i'm listening to something
she'll poke me and i'm like oh oops i'll file that away for
later no you're in trouble now i am i think you would scream
an obsession do you know anything about it i just know it's
creepy okay there's some like i heard it's yondering it i
love how now i know exactly what that means i i was so i
would like have not had time to go see it but i was so like
because i've just been watching like analysis videos on it
and so i was like are you reading the book synopsis no no it
made me want to see it more it made me like legitimately i
was just like oh because i was like looking at stuff about
like the camera work and like she's gonna good reads or
whatever like your book or she's not even gonna read it
she's gonna oh shut up everybody is getting on me
everybody's in the chat but i literally already said this on
stream i said i watched stuff about it and it made me want
to watch more and everybody agreed with me and now because i
have two beautiful women they're saying one one woman and a
half it's fine that are that are against me you guys are
against me i have a really embarrassing story that i want to
share okay okay when i was like in my in my early 20s there
was some guy i was working with at the restaurant or
something and i liked him or something like that and he was
telling me he likes movies and I was like I haven't seen a
lot of movies but you know what we should because we were
like planning a date I'm like we should do a date where we
watch like 30 trailers on YouTube and then kind of like pick
out I don't think I use the term battle royale but but like
kind of like battle royale them and find the best one and I
goes that's the worst fucking idea I've ever heard wait he
suggested the idea and then you said it was terrible no no
no no oh no I was like what we should do is we should sit
down because we like loves movies right I was like let's
watch like 30 random movie trailers and then if any of them
really pop up for us we can be like let's watch these three
let's watch this because i thought you know like i'm a big
quality yeah and he was like that is the worst thing i've
ever heard what's wrong he's like i never watched trailers
trailers or whatever i was like oh my god that's cool that's
so mean i was like this guy's mean i don't like that's so
mean i feel you know it's embarrassing if you shoot your
shot and then it doesn't work out but don't be mean about it
right yeah i will say that like i think a bunch of movie
spoil stuff but i went i watched the trailer for like
project tale mary and it didn't say anything and then i went
and watched it and i was like i was like whoa no it spoils
so much the one i watched didn't i guess i'm it oh okay then
i won't say yeah i don't watch any movie no you should go
see it's good it's so good do watch along do watch along not
a bad idea yeah my watermelon after being spiked so yammer's
sorry i just wasn't coming off the fork i'm like being a
little grainy yeah you are i'm your grainy we got covet
together in a hotel room in the same hotel room i literally
told like seven people sometimes she'll just bring it up
unprompted like we'll be We were at the Ace Combat thing.
That was the last time you brought it up.
And we were talking to somebody random.
And she was like, we got COVID together.
Okay, how many beds, though, in the hotel room, too?
But they were very close.
I will say, I remember Mint was like a little upset.
Because the hotel that you had seen, it looked very
different.
Yeah, yeah.
So it's all we got.
It was supposed to be like...
With our suitcases, like, it wouldn't...
It was supposed to be an apartment-style hotel.
And it was like just an upscale hotel.
But not really upscale.
It's like just a little bit bigger.
I got COVID a few days before.
If you know how COVID works, like it probably was
incubating.
So it's not.
You had it first.
Of course.
Yeah, and then he gave it to me because we were in the same
room.
It was my first time having COVID.
It was my second time.
I've had it like three times now.
No.
Okay, so for me, my first time having COVID, I was in
Australia.
My second time, I was in Japan.
So now I'm like, I just should never go.
No, I was scared when I travel.
I might have it right now.
No.
Wait, I forgot about that.
Australia everything.
Oh my god.
I got COVID in Australia for the first time.
Yeah, I remember that.
That's crazy.
Where did you get your COVID?
Where were you when your first COVID was here?
Here.
My third time getting COVID was right now.
Now, literally I'm diagnosed.
I didn't go downstairs to get more drinks.
I went to go take a COVID test.
Oh, good times.
You had it three times.
I'm so is that not normal?
You're not had it three times.
I've had it two when she got it.
one yeah oh my god one two three no i think like from
everybody i know most people it's good they gotta like once
or twice um actually uh wait how many times have you had
covid someone said i had it three times i've had it three or
four my people my people or four oh my god yeah wait how
would you three or four how do you think two times okay
that's two twice a lot of twos one zero Twice to.
A lot of twos.
Some threes.
Show me the threes.
Type three, even if you haven't had it three times.
Three, three, three.
Show me the threes.
One, one, one, one, one.
Oh, they're trying to make you feel better.
Zero, zero, zero.
I feel like I'm reading binary.
Well, you're accidentally like, show me.
Look, look, the threes.
The threes are coming.
Look, the threes.
Where's the eight zero zero eights?
I truly, did anybody have code five times?
I don't think logistically, like, Someone said seven.
I don't believe you.
Are you lying?
Okay, that's lying.
I mean, what if you don't take a test and you don't know?
Yeah, you don't know.
So when I was flying back from Australia, you had to get a
COVID test to fly out.
So I got my COVID test at the airport.
And then I had my COVID test to the guy and he's like, man,
did you take a look at this?
No.
No, he goes, you can't leave.
You have COVID.
Nothing.
No symptoms.
I was so embarrassed.
What if it was a false positive though?
I almost spit out my dream.
Never make her laugh like that.
You're never...
Guys, why did I agree to this?
Why am I hosting?
I'm the one in the chair.
Thanks so much for inviting me!
I'm in the chair, you guys.
My own hotel room.
You just have to pour me like three glasses of champagne.
I'll laugh at anything.
So true.
But you were already very giggly before that.
It's true.
Yeah.
I like it.
You definitely are an enabler in the best way.
I am.
Except for men becoming an alcoholic.
Oh, look.
Only pre-existing alcoholics.
Wait.
What?
How?
We don't know.
What do you mean?
You might really love it.
I might be calling you up all night being like, Nimmy.
Nimmy nightmare.
You're like, Nimmy, I got a nightmare.
Did we come suck my dread?
Come bring your leeches.
Do you have anything for my humor?
Your femur?
Humors.
She looked me dead at the eye.
Your femur?
Your femur is like, oh is femur on here or on the leg?
thigh.
I know because I'm certified nurse.
You heard it here first, folks.
Wait, have you guys played Dr. Wordle?
Dr. Wordle?
Is it like Wordle?
Yes.
Wait, explain it.
It's like Wordle, but you get symptoms of somebody who's
sick and you have to guess what disease they have.
Wait, that's awesome.
Okay, that's so funny.
That's literally somebody did the WebMD thing.
Okay, so what What are your...
Well, let's play it right now.
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Wait, there's one that I saw recently, too, that was, like,
poop-doll?
What?
No!
No, no!
You start with a word, and you have to, you can only change
one letter at a time, and then you have to get it to poop.
So, wait, it starts, you go, P. It goes, you go, P-O.
Yeah, yeah, you just...
B-O-O.
It just takes four.
No, why?
It's four.
It's four, it's all like it.
I win every time.
It's more complicated than that.
Hold on.
I really want to play your doctor game.
I know me too.
Me, a fool, changes the letter to a D.
No, it's poo.
And we all just rag on you like that, idiot.
Why would you do that?
Your rookie mistake.
So see what you do is you start with the P, and then you do
double O, and then you do P. That's the trap.
It's so funny.
Okay, I have dark turtle up.
Perfect.
A 34-year-old woman presents to her primary care physician
with complaints of persistent fatigue and difficulty
concentrating at work.
ADHD.
Okay, I'm putting it in.
It would be the opposite.
I'm just spitballing.
Incorrect.
She reports that these symptoms have been present for the
past six weeks and are present nearly every day.
Your turn.
Oh, lupus.
Oh, that's a good one.
Incorrect.
Oh, she also endorses poor appetite, insomnia, and feeling
slowed down.
Tyroid.
Oh.
You mean thyroid?
Did you?
What do you mean?
What do you mean when I mean thyroid?
What do you mean thyroid?
Thyroid.
Thyroid, right?
The thyroid, right?
Yeah, thyroid.
Thyroid.
Yeah.
Did you say thyroid?
She said thyroid.
I, I, my, my accent sometimes.
that's a little racist don't you okay thyroid I'm getting
the Google Doc okay but which one oh does it give you iodine
excess hypothyroidism the lower one I think it's hypo right
yeah hypo but do you want iodine excess congenital or iodine
deficiency oh iodine deficiency oh anything deficient
incorrect iron Ooh, that's a good guess.
That's a good guess.
When asked further, she admits to feeling worthless and
having recurrent thoughts of death, though she denies
actually suicidal ideas.
Depression, depression, depression.
Say it, say it, it's your turn, say it.
Depression.
Oh, she would come on.
This game is amazing.
Correct!
She's got depression.
Okay, can I go now?
This is so fun.
Wait, that was it.
That was the date.
You have to wait till tomorrow.
Aw.
That was the daily doctoral.
Can we do yesterday?
I'm gonna do the poo-poo.
Can we do yesterdays?
Rick, we can, we can.
Oh, okay, good, good, good.
I wanted to do it, but since you already did it, you know
what it is.
I wanted to do it for you guys.
Yesterdays?
I didn't do yesterdays.
Can I do it?
Can I do it then?
You can.
It's a little sad on the first line.
Wait, what does it say?
I don't know.
I'm so sorry if I laugh, guys.
I laugh all the time.
Okay, so I have to read, okay.
Oh.
of recurrent miscarriages.
Uh, uh, uh, depression.
None.
Incorrect.
She reports two recent pregnancies that ended in
miscarriage.
She also notes a recent increase in the heaviness of her
menstrual cycle.
This is so sad.
I know.
Do you want to do a different one?
We can do a different one.
I think it's fine.
We're doctors.
This is serious.
Do you want me to read it again?
She reports two recent pregnancies that ended in miscarriage
she also notes a recent increase in the heaviness of her
menstrual cycle wait what's the one where your uterine
lining grows outside your uterus oh no ovarian cancer oh
what's the name help us help us help us what's when your
uterus grows outside your uterus when your uterine lining
goes outside the uterus.
Endometriosis.
Yeah, endometriosis.
Endo.
Okay, there's endometriosis.
Okay, endometriosis.
Okay, perfect.
Yeah.
Endometriosis.
Sorry, I'm learning.
Incorrect.
Careful questioning reveals fatigue, weight gain,
depression, and constipation over the same time.
It's not cyst.
Try cyst.
Yeah, cyst.
Did we try that already?
No.
No, I said depression.
Sorry.
Okay, so there's a There's serous sista genoma.
Sorry, I get on my accent.
Gaglion cyst.
Tainius solium.
We did have u- ovarian?
Ovarian.
Ovarian cyst is a good one.
Ovarian cyst.
Let me see.
Ovarian torsion.
Cis.
They have ovarian corpus luteal cyst.
Ovarian tecalutean cyst.
Ovarian follicular cyst.
That sounds like something I've heard before.
Follicular.
What do you think?
Yeah, yeah.
Sure.
Ovarian follicular cysts submit a physical exams reveals a
diffusely enlarged non-tender thyroid thyroid you guys guess
depression endometriosis ovarian follicular cysts wait is it
hypothyroid oh try it yeah we tried that congenital
congenital hypothyroidism oh my god oh my god it's also
called cretinism that's mean that's mean I have
hypothyroidism in front of my family That's mean.
She's literally pointing and laughing, you guys.
That's mean.
I've been drinking.
That's funny.
I'm not a crit.
I never, I never said anything.
I just pointed and laughing.
You did play the single game.
No.
Okay.
Incorrect.
Laboratory tests show elevated TSH and low T4.
T, what's a T4?
What are those?
That's taxes.
That's your tax forms.
Oh, are they supposed to be hot?
That's thyroid.
It's the other one.
Okay.
The other thyroid.
Hypothyroid.
Thyroid.
Okay.
Thyroid medullary carcinoma.
No, that's carcinoma's cancer.
Thyroid papillary carcinoma.
Hashimoto thyroid is this.
Ectopic thyroid.
How do you do this?
Lingual thyroid.
Wait, ectopic.
Ectopic?
Yeah.
With an E or an A?
Ectopic?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
yeah yeah that has to do with your uterus can you I don't
know if I'm just typing that I can't you like take the phone
and it says like it says lingual that means tongue be it
can't be wait what's a lingual your tongue what about cancer
it could be just put ovarian cancer ovarian cancer okay
because that feels like a cop-out you know like you know hmm
how do you say that as a dog Dokey said hag to hag to hag
community.
This game is amazing.
I can't believe it.
Is it so easy to reach?
Wait, endometrial carcinoma.
Try it, try it.
Oh yeah, carcinoma is like cancer.
It's incorrect.
What was it?
No, it's antithyroid peroxidase antibodies.
I was going to say that next.
One more guess.
Oh.
Antithyroid peroxidase.
bodies are detected in the blood.
Wait, I think it didn't.
It's like an inflammatory thyroid or something.
If it's like an infection, infection.
She might actually be a nurse.
It's the white blood cells.
You might actually be a nurse.
That's not an option.
Just say, um, it's something with the thyroid.
Thyroid.
And the ovaries.
Ovaries, sorry.
Ovaries.
There are ovaries.
And I'm excited.
I can, I can.
I just know how to react, I'm so sorry.
I don't know.
Why would they call it that?
Why?
Why would they?
That's messed up.
That's like the old term from the...
Why would they choose that?
I don't know, they stuck people in addicts for being sick
and stuff too.
ATTIC?
What?
Oh, ATTIC?
ATTIC?
Yeah, there's like the problem rooms or whatever.
They used to stick like the behavioral like children with
issues and stuff like you know behavioral issues and they
would be like Yeah, this is the it's like a disappointment
room.
That's what it's called.
It's so mean The disappointment.
I think it's pseudo pseudo pseudo hypoparathyroidism.
I agree.
I was actually gonna say that I was gonna say that my tongue
I was Hashimoto.
No, it was Hashimoto.
I have a tick tock for that What?
Can you do the day before?
before.
Yeah.
Before we get canceled.
We're invested in this now.
This game is, this is such a funny game.
You better, you gotta start playing the doctordal on your
stream.
Yeah, yeah, I might.
Oh, see, here's poop, poople.
Stop trying.
Oh my god, it really is just four letters.
No, watch, watch.
So now you have to change it.
So now, but the, each word has to be an actual word.
So it's nail.
And then they do pale.
Oh, I see.
And then that's the one word.
And then you can do like, mmm.
And then you have to figure out what word you use with like
pool, you know, you can only change one thing at a time.
So paid.
Paid.
I see.
You see, it's a little more intuitive than just putting in.
Okay.
She keeps not just keeping one letter.
No, she gets, she, she realized.
But you have to kind of work it down to like then be like
pair.
Okay.
So now you like, she's like, oh, I went back, but see, it's
a little more intuitive.
Then, okay.
No, I don't know.
Hashimoto's.
Okay, it's your turn to me.
Oh my God.
Okay, a 21-year-old male.
Wait, I did this one.
You do it, though.
You do it.
I did this one.
You read.
You do it.
I will play.
You read.
Just don't give us any hints.
Sorry for making you read.
This one is sad, too, though.
Oh.
I don't know how to tell you this without it coming off
crazy.
All of them are sad.
None of them, you're like, this one is sad.
Oh, this one today was really happy.
It was ovarian cancer.
That was really a happy one.
What if it's hypothyroidism?
get to laugh because I have that all right what if someone
has happy disease well we were to I was talking about it's
on my stream are they Bruno Mars is Bruno Mars happy cuz I'm
happy my jokes get worse as the night progresses Bruno Mars
is it no that's Rick Astley no no are you the one drinking
right the one drinking.
No, see, it's Pharrell.
Oh, okay, it was Pharrell.
Was it not Pharrell and Bruno Mars?
But it wasn't Rick Astley.
Oh, it's, it's a Rick Pharrell, no?
Or maybe, I think you should develop a drinking habit.
I think this would go hard.
I think it would be really funny.
I've had so much orange juice.
You guys, I'm really feeling this orange juice.
Yeah, I'm glowing.
I'm feeling it.
All right, I'm ready.
You're never going to get what is the teeth, uh, scurvy.
Oh no!
Wait, I want to be a pirate though.
Okay, I'm listening.
A 21-year-old male college student is brought into the
clinic by his parents for declining grades, increasing
social isolation, and poor hygiene over the last year.
ADHD.
It was not ADHD.
Okay.
On interview, the patient said, speaks in vague tangential
sentences that are difficult to follow.
Porn addiction is not on there.
Let me type it.
It's not on there.
Okay, repeat the second phrase.
No, you're not even listening.
On interview, the patient speaks in vague tangential
sentences that are difficult to follow.
Brain tumor.
Yeah, brain.
Is it an aneurysm?
is that a brain tumor there's a word for that um do
aneurysms like a n e u r y a s m a n e u r y s m it's not on
there what about stroke oh yeah yeah yeah stroke oh yeah
that's good my grandpa had that which stroke there's many oh
uh read them i'll know when i hear it i'll know when i
Locked in.
I know.
Ischemic stroke, central post stroke pain syndrome.
Ischemic stroke, lacunar stroke.
Ischemic stroke, ischemic stroke.
That one?
This is a really sad one, by the way, guys.
Remember that.
It is.
Are we close?
Are we hot or cold?
Oh.
You're cold.
We're cold.
But you can get it.
You know what you know.
Is it a degenerative disease of the brain?
Kuru.
I don't know.
No, don't actually write Kudo.
Don't actually write Kudo.
I don't think it's going to be a cannibal.
Cannibal mention...
You have a little special thing for cannibal?
Yes.
What?
But I'm usually the one to bring it up.
Why?
I love cannibalism.
Cannibalism.
I am cannibal.
Yes.
Yeah.
I know.
I sing it because of you.
You gotta show it to me.
It's Kesha song.
Oh, cannibal, no.
I'm gonna eat you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes.
Okay, wait, what's your guess?
Oh.
It's not an aneurysm.
It's not...
Unless we don't know how to spell aneurysm.
I mean...
Which is possible.
Okay, okay.
Mommos and with...
Napplings.
Sorry.
If you guys could please tell us how to spell an aneurysm.
One time.
I'll scroll up and see if anyone's spelled it.
No, they're gonna spoil it because if they watch my stream
two days ago, they know.
Oh, they know, they know.
They're gonna know.
Hey guys, it's so exciting to see you today.
So today...
Yes!
Oh here, A-N-E-U-R-Y-S-M.
That's what I said.
Yeah, that's what I said.
Oh, I didn't put the Y.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Did you write like aneurysm?
I wrote it with an I.
Aneurysm.
I feel like if you already wrote like aneurysm, they should
know.
Okay, but which one do you want?
The sub-archnoid, hemorrhage, berry, ash.
Oh, hemorrhage, hemorrhage.
Hemorrhage is good.
It's incorrect.
that it's incorrect because I did it two days ago.
But you're doing good.
You're playing.
If you're doing good, I wouldn't have been able to tell.
I felt very like encouraged.
You're going to know the clue after this.
Oh, really?
Okay.
You overestimate us.
His affect is markedly flat even when discussing the recent
death of a family member.
What's an affect?
I was just about to ask that.
I love you.
Like his, you know, his personality.
Oh, his demeanor.
His demeanor.
Okay.
We already said depression.
You didn't.
Depression?
Depression.
But then why is he speaking in tongues?
Because he's really depressed, man.
Don't make, don't laugh.
You're laughing.
It's incorrect.
Okay, what is it?
The patient whispers to you that the government agency has
implanted a tracking device in his head and is monitoring
his thoughts.
Is it schizophrenia?
Yeah, schizophrenia, but bipolar.
Or, uh, yeah.
Schizophrenia, sure.
You are right, we were going to guess.
She's writing it in and it's wrong and like she's not even
making a face.
I know!
If that is wrong, you are God level.
It was schizophrenia.
It would have been so funny if you just wrote it down.
I can laugh.
My sister has that.
I'll drink to that.
To her help.
I'm out of a drink.
You have a whole orange juice.
I have what?
I filled it.
She drank it down.
You drank it all down?
I told you I'm so full of orange juice.
water no I'm I don't need water I'm I'm so yeah juice me up
yeah there's no more mangoes so you're gonna have to do just
OJ but I got you the big the big jug yes I'll put it down
for the good luck juice me up no wonder you're laughing at
schizophrenia my god this game is amazing straight you need
to play it on stream i love you so much and i appreciate
would you like some more or are you good for now i can't say
no just are you having more of course okay are you gonna go
at her level maybe maybe you can keep up with her though
well i'm like a heavyweight because i'm british and and
german that's my ancestry so like i can't either no but i've
been to both my genetics make me a heavyweight despite my
petite stash or beside this despite being so petite she's so
petite the booba will de-alcohol all the time it's true oh
she spilled him Matawa my tower spilling I'm gonna get mad
at me like I love that you're so No, no, no, no, no, I
didn't mean it like that.
I just mean, like, it's so funny that you log in every day
and you're like, oh, this one is sad today.
Like, they're sad every day.
Sometimes they're more sad than others.
Sometimes it's a four-year-old.
I can't even do the ones where it's a four-year-old.
What's next?
Like, you're going to be like, all right, so let's ring.
This world of the day, S-tier, sad.
This one, D-minus.
Yeah, yeah.
This is, this is, it's like somebody's every day.
It's like the trolley problem.
Do you run over the old lady or do you run over the baby?
You run over the old lady.
Yeah.
Yeah, true.
Yeah, so fuck.
I should not have said that.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
I'll leave the juice here forever.
Yeah, leave the juice.
Mint's addicted.
Mint's strange addiction is just orange.
Can't juice me up.
How big is this?
You're actually probably not going to fall asleep with the
sugar high.
Oh, my God.
I forgot it has sugar in there.
what it's juice it's all sugar you're so right and the six
macaroons no it's using gentle flavor what what is gentle
flavor it's got it's it's got sugar i don't know how to
break this to you oh man okay i'll stop here i'll stop here
she says having a full glass of undranked juice oh it's a
quart and a half okay but we also have been drinking it yeah
Yeah, I didn't, I drunk probably the most of the juice.
Yeah, I will crash so hard.
I'll sleep really good tonight.
We have to work tomorrow, too.
That's so funny.
We have to do the poop doll.
Yeah, we have to.
Are we going to poop doll?
Yeah, real?
Okay.
We're making fun of you, but, like, of course we're going to
do it.
Okay, yippee!
I've never done it before.
What?
You've never done it, but you're talking about it?
I'm excited.
Let's go.
it's poop this is okay so it's the first and the last
everybody this is how you play poop doll play the daily word
ladder change one letter at a time every step must be a
valid word so we start with show we have to think ahead yeah
exactly and you can you have to kind of like oh already has
an oh there so we couldn't yeah we already have oh what if
we did change it oh we could but shop
wait shop seems good shop is good shop is good and then soup
and then soup soup is great wait soup with a is it with a
you you want to change the letters you wanted to say poop
soup with soup with two o's it's not real i'm being rejected
okay so what are we at what are we at soup with two o's okay
shop so we just need okay pop like i hop like what i hop
like pop like i hop um oh wait no no no no no that's not a
real mid mid mid that's not a I take offense to that.
No, we can always bring it back.
I know, now we have no other word we can go to.
And I don't have chat to cheat with.
Wait, no, no, no, no.
Let's start with a B and just think of words.
Shop, uh.
Wait.
Pop.
We can only change one letter.
Stop?
It can only be so many things.
Is stop real?
Oh, wait, that doesn't really...
Oh, I see what you mean.
Yeah.
We're stuck.
We have to go back.
we go back to show we can no we can yeah we might have sorry
i got i have a capitalism whole um wait oh i was gonna say
flop what about plop but we can't put the l oh oh slop whoa
you're so smart slop okay okay wait how does this help us at
least now we're like we got more now we can go a block yeah
and then and then poop oh my god i'm sorry for sabotaging
you guys it wasn't all purpose i just was really excited the
poop till in five that was really good yeah tweet that tweet
that share on x
it would be so funny if we actually got like poop till
number 10 easy it would be so so funny if we got people
being like um actually i got the google like all the like
poop i hope it like doesn't dock so i did okay oh uh just
screenshot it oh i already posted it
show to poop in four steps perfect i'm sorry i don't have a
cool game to show you guys
we did it everybody start doing that every day on your
stream.
I think you should.
I'm back to chat, everybody, sorry about that.
No, they loved it.
What did they think?
Yeah, what did you guys think?
Did you like that?
Were you impressed?
Yeah.
How?
Everybody should start poop-dolling.
Your daily poop-doll.
I mean, you should poop-doll every day.
You should, actually.
While you are pooping, you poop-doll.
Wait, that's good.
That's smart.
Yeah.
But you shouldn't use your phone while you're pooping,
because you'll get hemorrhoids.
Or you'll get, even worse, you can get a prolapsed anus.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
What does hemorrhoids have to do with you pooping?
Because you sit on the toilet for too long.
Yeah, and when you're on the toilet, no, gravity is pulling
down on you.
Oh my God, sometimes I read a book.
No, you shouldn't.
You shouldn't.
You're going to get a prolapsed anus from you.
You know what's your butthole to fall out of your butthole.
Yeah.
No, that's bad.
That's bad.
It's bad.
It's really bad.
I literally sometimes like read books.
Because I like, so I literally will sit down and then I put
my head like, and I like disassociate.
I'm gonna get a prolapse.
You are, you are!
You're gonna have to use those pillows for your foot.
It just feels good, like, to feel depressed.
No, no, to feel depressed, you know, like you just like...
Well, be depressed in the bathtub instead.
That's a great idea.
Are we doing the thing of the day?
I spend long hours on the toilet.
What's the symptom?
Major depressive disorder.
In Vegas we had a like in our hotel room.
I had a really big bath So I bought not one not three, but
two bath bombs for my bath and I disassociated Did you use
it at the same time?
I did.
Wow.
Did it have jets?
I didn't put on the jet.
Oh, but it can be gross.
I have the most first world problem So I'm pretty tall and
like long.
So a lot of baths I kind of have to you know put my knees up
and it's not great This bath was so long and I was like
slipping in.
I had to actually wet myself and I couldn't really relax in
it wow you don't float what are bugs filled with bug juice
bug meat bug meat bug meat you don't float i'm filled with
the remains of my ex-husbands oh okay i eat them the heads
mostly right the whole body i eat no parts wasted yeah
because it's it if you're a widow there's a little bit of a
stigma but if they all die in like horrific animal accidents
veganism is not for you can take up a new hobby yeah yeah
it's great um i've never tried it cannibalism or baths yeah
both one of those i can recommend cannibalism yes you may
promise me that one day we would go to onsen you're inviting
oh i thought you were gonna say we would eat each other's i
was like the onset is too hot for me i believe it does get
really hot hot it does yeah you just don't want to hear i
just put my little feats in well i feel like i'm being
cooked like i'm no no they are really hot you can go to like
the last one i went to was outside and it was winter yeah so
it was really nice or sometimes it's really good it's like
you're in your hotel and you have like the big kind of like
literally a big tub bath yeah you just all sit with your
drink but you all like stare at the window so it's not
awkward because you're not like oh yeah you know you're just
like i stared at their breasts for everybody wondering if
it's big enough but you're kind of like chilling like this
and you're just all staring in the same direction and like
yapping you know and you're like I was gonna say if it's big
enough you lay and then your feet become like a star like
you're all like kind of laying what like your toes I don't
know how to float then because I just sink in the bath I
guess dang it's all my bug mash it's all your bug mass my
baby I only know how to float you got big yeah I didn't
realize that maybe I don't know how to float that's like a
really important thing to know though because if you like I
don't know how to drive stranded in the ocean I know how to
swim no but you get tired of swimming so you have to know
how to float oh it's over she's gonna get hemorrhoids she's
gonna float in the ocean I'm done I'm fish food I think we
should make it a little bit colder yeah I'm getting a little
hot go turn on the air okay I have to go to the bathroom
again how come you guys don't have to you broke the seal you
broke the seal should i mute it yeah you want to put the
little oh you can was that so loud i didn't no and also we
were honestly like we got closer to the mic and we kept yeah
yeah don't worry about it yeah this is what we were doing
actually we were going to go actually oh that's a good idea
that's a great idea i have to the juice I'm having so much
fun thanks for inviting me yeah I'm sorry she likes me more
than you that's fine and it happens every time I'm not cruel
I'm gonna wait I think I just accidentally ate off her fork
that was her fork that's her fork wait where's yours then I
don't know is that yours that was my fork oh I was so scared
I'm like no I think she would have been fine with it though
I know are you jealous I'm gonna kick you guys out soon
though I gotta I gotta go to sleep Yeah, you do Yeah, I do
Yeah, I do If you don't, we're just gonna alcoholic tag it
up I know, and then I'm You're gonna be stuck here No, I can
get out of here She's gonna get out of here, guys I'm eeppy
I don't What is this, like, little emoji thing That people
are doing?
Oh, they're head patting you It's like a little pat So
they're being like this one with the like the parentheses
and the plus sign I wonder if it's like cat ears what is
that you guys I wonder what is that I wonder I don't know oh
there it's Nimmy's ears oh it's because your fork was there
oh I see it now I see it they're making like little tapier
ears in the chat yeah that's what they do when I go to the
tapier meeting oh okay okay because I because I go down you
won't see my oh yeah i like that i don't look at your chat i
think she's gonna kick us out soon because yeah it's getting
kicking yeah i'm surprised it's almost nine i know no crazy
yeah you're right fun time it's been a time to move by your
girls are so welcome for the good time thank you for the
champagne and the orange juice mint you're gonna text me at
3am being like i can't sleep We have the worst thing that
like I at night I get really tired and she gets the craziest
zoomies Oh, I do what he gets like zoomie.
I do running around and I do and I get a Victorian child
where I'm like I'm feeling it a little bit Mr. Krabs me it's
the morning.
I wake up.
I'm like good morning sunshine.
It's time to live the day and she's like We shut the fuck
up.
Let me sleep No, I do get hype.
Yeah at a like at night at night you're like a.m.
yeah like 11 midnight oh boy 3 a.m.
that's true I don't know I get like a second wind and I
always feel like oh I should just go to sleep at like 10 p
.m.
or something I mean that's real that's real and then you get
to the witching hour yeah over you don't want to stay up
till 3 a.m.
I do I don't know I get sad at 3 a.m.
oh don't you get sad at the alcohol girl no when I'm sober
you get thought you've ever had kind of comes into your mind
and you're like yes I wonder if my great grandpa would be
proud of me yes yes and it's like I think I'm the only
person awake in the entire world in the entire universe I'm
the only one I'm all alone I diagnosed you with prolapse
anus it's like it's like a magic wand No,
I get it though.
They say, like, don't trust your thoughts after 9 p.m.
Yes, exactly.
That's why I go to sleep at midnight, you know?
Yeah.
And then you don't have to worry about it.
You don't have to wake up and you're happy.
I have to pee.
Go, good.
It's not just me.
Go fifth, girl.
I'm peeing.
We should took the chat with her.
Oh, sorry.
She wants to watch them while she pees.
Yeah.
I'll talk to them if I can.
I don't know what you guys are saying.
I'm gonna stop doing that because I legit like disassociate
and like read well that's that's why I stopped because I
learned the terrors that can happen oh fuck no I definitely
am done after this glass because I'm feeling it a little bit
mr.
crabs me too but you're finally a vtuber who's who drinks
and is also not like drunk after one glass it's true and I
barely I had to take a nap today because I flew in from from
the Las Vegas so I'm I had to take a little nap that's
that's fair it was like a seven minute wait it was yes it
was it was sometimes when you nap it's like time dilates and
it's like just really makes a difference sometimes it's like
just getting better but I took yesterday I took like a 1.5
hour nap and it was terrible yeah there's always like a
weird timing where like sometimes longer isn't better it's
true what's your perfect nap time.
Nine hours.
I'm the same.
Why don't you nap?
I'm like, because my naps last.
If I don't get nine hours of sleep, don't talk to me.
I cannot.
Like, I need the extra hours.
I'm already kind of like resting bitch face and like my tone
of voice.
And if I don't sleep, I can't smile.
Oh gosh, I sleep so much.
And sometimes I'm like, is it bad?
But I love to sleep.
I feel like I have a little bit of like attachment issues
and sleep is death, but like less commitment you know like
death is like dramatic I know sometimes I'm scared of death
but then I remember like well I'd love to sleep so how
different can it be and the time I'm not sure if you like
sometimes when I'm feeling kind of sad and it's like I ate a
good food I did I'm just sad I don't know why I go to take a
nap or asleep especially on the couch you're feeling really
sad you sleep on the couch you wake up you're like life is
so it just it feels amazing everyone should sleep and y'all
should nap and nap couch naps though I don't know what it is
about it's better than bed naps because bed naps I feel like
they confuse you they do like I should have been sleeping at
least your soul's not sure it's like this is not my way yeah
yeah but a couch couch is good couch naps oh versus bed naps
are you a napper I'm a bed napper I don't know if I get into
a bed for a nap seven hours oh no I just do like 20 or 40
minutes because 40 minutes would be like two REM cycles and
then But you're min-maxing!
I just pray to God.
But how do you know that you're gonna fall asleep?
Yeah, how do you know that you're gonna REM?
I give myself a couple extra minutes.
You can fall asleep in a few minutes?
No, that's why I give myself like 10 extra minutes.
You can fall asleep in 10 minutes?
Okay, wait, what do you do to fall asleep in 10 minutes?
I don't, if I'm that tired, I'm taking a nap.
That's why I'm taking a nap.
I don't know, it takes me like 30 minutes or an hour.
What?
Because you have like the thoughts in your head.
Yeah, yeah.
The inner monologue is going.
You have to like go, there's like a movie in your head and
you have to watch the movie before you fall asleep.
Yes, exactly, exactly.
I have too much anxiety for that.
I'm thinking about everything that's ever happened bad in my
afterlife.
That's the movie.
It says horror.
So look, does your movie only play for 10 minutes?
Are you only anxious about 10 minutes?
I can find like so many more things for you to be anxious
about.
No, I have a lot of anxiety.
I'm dying.
i love you i'm with you yeah we're team anxiety team anxiety
i don't know neuroticism yeah it's like anxiety but like in
in like the dramatic sense i'll turn around and i just see
your feet maybe i got manicured toes i know they're a little
sunburned from like me why are you looking at you polish on
i do i do yeah i had to redo it soon though you do a little
white toesies i like this polish because it kind of looks
like those like greek phases because it's blue and like gold
spots.
Oh that's what that does.
I do feel a little bit like why are we staring at
Why shouldn't we?
Why not?
Let's give ourselves a hard cut off.
Otherwise we're gonna keep yapping Oh two minutes.
Okay a little bit softer cut off please.
You said a hard cut off.
Like can it be a little bit softer than two minutes?
You said a little bit softer than two minutes.
You It's at a hard cutoff.
Okay, but I wouldn't talk to her.
What time is it now?
It's 8.58.
Yeah.
Can we do 907?
Okay.
Sure.
Whatever you want, Mataricon.
Yeah.
I'm tired.
You're tired?
You're not tired?
We're both buzzed.
At least I am.
YouTube.
I told her, I'm like, I'm done after this glass because
otherwise I'm going to keep...
I can't keep drinking orange juice, you guys.
I'm not on your level.
I gotta, I gotta quit.
It's really silly.
Thank you for drinking.
It was fun.
Not you.
I had a drink.
You're drinking orange juice with this.
Orange juice doesn't care.
Oh, I should have mixed the orange and the apple juice.
For tomorrow.
Now you're getting wild.
I know.
You're getting crazy.
You're right, you're right.
You have it for tomorrow.
I know, and I have more.
yeah make sure you drink water though because i don't want
you having a headache i'll drink so much water you know i've
never had a hangover i think it's my my german british genes
i'm like genetics have built me to drink literal alcohol in
your blood i know i know i'm so envious it wasn't that bad
for me but i think when i hit like my early 30s it suddenly
became like if i one pint of dark beer even if i drink water
next day i have a hangover that could be me any minute you
have water in your room right i do but i'm telling you like
something just flipped one day and i'm like darn it's bad
also um i never used to get migraines and i started getting
my remember i told you before like we were just practicing
we get them a lot i get them a lot now and i know it's a
migraine because it literally like i feel right now no no no
no like i'll feel like here and here and stuff i'm like oh
my god my body is deteriorating it is at an alarming rate
what if the next role i started early but it's like old age
i found a gray hair my first gray hair yesterday yesterday
my first white hair it's somewhere here i saw it it's it's
in the bangs you gotta own it like get more i almost plucked
it but then i was like no i'm not gonna be i'm not gonna
pluck it that's my it's your hackism it's your hack to hack
communication.
Hack to hack to hack.
Hack to hack.
I wonder what, I'm definitely going to go back into the VOD
and like re-listen to some of it where we're like, hmm.
Someone says don't tell Doki.
Does Doki have grades?
She has.
My baby.
I don't know because I would dye my hair.
I dye my hair blonde for a long time and now I'm dyeing my
hair so I can't actually know.
Well, it's, it must have been there for a while because
it's, it's long.
I feel like they grow faster.
Napalinks, are you guys stressing her the fuck out?
No.
What the heck?
Don't tell me what.
Doki, she's saying you're grage.
I don't know.
They're hag maxing.
Doki send me so many food pictures from Korea today.
Oh yeah.
What are you eating, Doki?
What are you eating?
Are you eating?
Are you eating topokie?
Topokie!
Actually, I don't know if there was...
She had like the tofu, like stew?
Are you eating stew in the Fuji game?
Because she knows K-pop.
She also had like the, what is it, like the bibimbap?
The bibimbap, bibimbap!
And yeah, it was awesome.
It was a lot of stuff.
Oh, spaghetti!
I'll eat sketti in any country.
I don't know.
Japanese sketti is kind of weird.
Napolitan is gross.
I don't like that.
Just give me shit because my poverty growing up meal was
spaghetti and ketchup.
Jolly bees is spaghetti and ketchup.
That's Napoleon.
Spaghetti and ketchup.
I don't know.
I don't know about the ketchup.
What's your guys's like go-to?
Like this is my struggle meal.
Olive oil pasta.
That's good.
Struggle meal.
Oh yeah, olive oil pasta.
Olive oil pasta rules.
I get like the pasta that's like called hidden veggies and
it's like a pasta made out of veggies.
So it's for kids that are like, I don't want to eat my
veggies.
So that's why there's hidden veggies, but I'm like, I'm
getting my veggies in.
Yeah, yeah.
Another one for me is bread, ketchup, and slice of American
cheese in the microwave.
It has to like...
Ketchup, not mustard?
I would do mustard.
I do ketchup.
I think the ketchup is better with the American cheese.
And then the American cheese has to like literally look like
plastic.
And then you kind of, if you're, you know, struggling, you
put it with your finger and you like put it back on or like
you like, because it's all like coagulated on the side.
Yeah.
I just do mac and cheese.
You do do mac and cheese a lot.
There's this vegan mac and cheese.
It's in the box called pasta abilities and it comes in the
shape of sea creatures.
And you have to get the one that's shaped like sea creatures
because the other ones don't taste as good.
They don't.
The naplings don't take this.
You should do a pasta in the shape of the naplings.
Oh, I should.
Maplings don't take this.
Like, okay.
So food.
Why are you talking to my phone?
she like leads out to talk to my phone I do that sometimes
when I talk to them I literally stare at the computer like
so foods that are like shelf stable are actually much easier
to make because it's kind of like merch right we're like you
can have a stored desk I stored a Pokemon mac and cheese in
my drawers yeah like you can throw like desk mats for a
while and and honestly you should really look into those
like shapes and like make them there yeah that would be cute
and if you have different iterations you can even do like
your and like little stuff yes and you can make a vegan pot
like you literally do like a vegan mac and cheese oh my gosh
and even if you know it's on something this it's at least
your thing and you can be like that's my vegan mac and
cheese possibility is my business email is nimi nightmare
dot mail at gmail.com you should someone said someone from
sets in a 3d printed eye blue shaped pasta what oh but wait
you can't eat it you can't eat it it's tin it's a I'm
Where's the Ibu pasta?
Densetsu Channel.
I want to see.
I haven't met them yet, I think.
Where's the Ibu pasta?
I need to eat.
And why didn't I see it?
But 3D printing pasta doesn't work because you can't eat it.
Why can't you?
If you're afraid.
It's pasta.
If you're coward.
Yeah.
There's already microplastics, so might as well.
We discussed this already.
We had this conversation.
We did.
okay have it with me now oh some people say i don't know if
it's true yeah they're starting on the balls everybody says
that there's enough microplastics in your balls to form a
spoon a plastic spoon that i didn't hear about in my like my
test yes we speak it could be the balls it could be the
brains nobody's quite sure everybody has different opinions
i have many doctors have talked tomorrow's doctor
And my brain.
So, yeah, they dream of spoons all the time.
Plastic spoons.
Well, it's because it's evocative.
Well, this is not plastic.
Thank goodness for the environment.
Because I almost stabbed you with it.
You're a plastic one.
Mine is plastic.
You hate the environment.
I do.
I say that all the time.
You are eating macaroons in front of your vegan friend,
telling her they're so delicious.
I'm making her smell them.
Oh, my God.
I do.
Do the worst.
I hate the environment.
I said it here first.
What has the environment ever done for me?
I hate touching grass.
You're laughing, but I can tell at her.
She's like laughing at me.
Only a little.
I can tell by your facial.
I love trees.
I love that environment.
I love the ocean.
The ocean should have less plastic.
I'll say it.
I'll be brave.
The ocean should have less plastic in it.
You're so brave.
Everybody clap.
Thank you.
in Canada it's a really big it's 907 oh it's a really big
part-time job in Canada for people to go up north and just
plant trees and you get paid for like each tree you plant
what you should look into it Johnny Appleseed I'll go you
probably could look it up but there's also like programs
where there's a lot of people what they do is like they
match it so usually people get paid something like 25 cents
for tree planted but you can always look up those programs
that seems that seems tough how long would it take you to
plant a tree you literally have to do 12-hour shift.
It would take me at least an hour to plant a tree.
You should look into programs that do matching.
There's a lot of programs for charity that kind of match
like tree planting stuff.
I'm gonna get paid 25 cents an hour.
I mean you have supported.
I mean you have supported tree replant together.
You're like you want me to stop streaming to go plant a
tree?
It's gonna take me an hour each tree to dig the hole no what
if they're really small they're really small you kind of
have like a little like um like trouble yeah yeah it's like
a little you go wait how big of a hole you literally plant
like you literally go the seed the seed you're planting the
seed to the future baby you're not planting like a tree
she's in here like digging up the room yeah it's gonna take
me a while to
killed a few breads do you have any uh plants at home okay
i'm i'm actually bad with plants i do not know i would have
never guessed it based on this conversation i'm good with
animals my cats live to be like 20 years old wow but my
plants die yeah me too the plants i think cats are much
easier did you guys hear about parasilton no she started
doing um red light therapy on her dogs and now they're
living to like 1819 which is crazy i'm gonna do that yeah
i'm gonna do that they're doing red light therapy you know
if you have a little mouse for red light do it on your cat
or you have like a little paddle they're gonna hate it
though no but they're gonna live long they're gonna hate it
look it up though they might need it's a different dog it's
a different they might need eye protection look it up does
it have to be their face or can it be their butt look it up
look up paris hilton red light it's like when your gerbil
dies and your parents I don't think Ferris Hilton's parents
at her age are replacing her dogs.
They could be.
She's like how old is she now?
She must be in like her early 40s.
She must be like mid 40s.
She must be like 28.
She has she's like an eternal 28 I feel like.
Yeah, she is.
She is.
Oh my god.
I said this but like so I've been no doubt show You know,
obviously like Gwen Stefani is under a lot of pressure to
stay young and good looking and everything She's a front
woman.
Some of the guys in the band like they look great by the way
But you can tell, like, Silver Fox, all white hair, big
beard.
Like, you can tell they're, like, maybe 50, something.
Gwen looks 30.
Oh.
Like, the difference in there, even though they're the same,
this is actually, like, her older brother's family.
Like, they're all the same age, and she is looking, like, 20
years younger than them.
But they look great.
Sounds like you had fun.
It was amazing.
Today's collab was fun.
I had a lot of fun.
I had too much fun.
I know you.
I know.
I'm sitting in my...
You invited two yeahers.
I'm here.
I have to, but...
I'm tired.
You tired of this grandma?
Yeah, I'm tired.
Say goodbye to them.
Yeah.
You tell them that you're kicking...
It's your channel.
And you tell them, it's your responsibility to tell them
that you're kicking us out.
I'm...
Me, Mint Phantom, I've made Mint Phantom channel.
With a fig tree.
I'm throwing them into the fig tree.
Yippee!
They are being figs.
I'm gonna be a macaron.
Yay!
for listening to us yeah this was a lot of fun I'm gonna
have to go through the bot I want to hear I want to talk
more but I don't like you know I want us to have the freedom
do you want to talk to them and I'll shut the fuck up and
she'll okay I can be quiet oh this is weird they're just
looking at me no no no talk to them I'll be quiet hey
they're looking at me they're looking at Please say goodbye.
We're respectful.
Why don't you guys say goodbye too?
It's your channel.
This is the end of the show.
Stop staring at me.
Bye.
I gotta go to the...
To get up to go to the OBS.
We have to start cutting it off.
Otherwise, we're never gonna leave.
I know.
Wow.
Wait, we all look physicians too.
Why?
Wow.
Also, it is starting to get late.